qui part hop ça c'est fait femme les
gens doivent nous voir moi je vais
récupérer les échiquiers nous d'eux me
voir jean linder 2,2 me voir ne
t'inquiète pas ça va ça va bien se
passer
ça va bien se passer la bascule tu y es
là bas qu'ils allaient blanc mais qui je
garde qui jouent eux quatre on va
prendre baky la cam de pas qui ils
arrivent en retard un retard c'est pas
alors 0,10 te dise qualificatifs 1 mais
ça c'est comme au rap contenders quand
tu prends une une antisèche quoi
interdite c'est interdit
magnus qui essaye déjà de d'utiliser le
règlement terrible et boit de l'eau en
plus non mais c'est un fait c'est
vraiment car victoire 1-0 enfin lens et
je sais pas si la tolérance zéro maxime
est ce qu il connaît la règle si c'est
tolérance zéro face est inadmissible
c'est normalement c'est pousser ses
forfaits direct bonsoir été une très
bonne journée
quel dommage mauvaise règles arbitres
entrée 16 voix qu'il arrive en retard ça
c'est un manque de respect par contre ce
qu'on parlait ce que machin la grave ça
c'est respecter sas qui arrivait en
retard entre deux tubes à fait exprimé
est-ce que c'est pas un manque de
respect fire tard rendez-vous tu arrives
à l'heure ouais bah il a un coeur d'or
pour arriver en fait c'est toi qui
sortent quand tu respectes une personne
t'arrive à leur nom enfin bon t'as sont
là on dira oui c'est un manque de
respect mais dans d'autres cas de figure
si c'était quelqu'un d'autre ça irait
j'aurais pu dire que des fois tu a
permis d'arriver trop avant pour pas
dire bonjour à tout le monde et perdre
sa concentration et dire écouter un
discours et est tout juste arrivé pour
jouer quoi mais quand tu joues contre un
président d'une d'une nation une race
est quand même entre le 4-5 kf3 les
pronostics étaient longs quoi
est ce qui va lui envoyer une écossaise
soit le fou va partir alors j'ai pas si
votre 3 4 4 cases fou bessines coraux et
les shows le présent alors petit
chevalet ci soit 6 1 6 4
sassus à 6 il va lui vaut une poussée
sine qua non il y avait une vad et des
rythmes je trouve à la force du
thatchérisme dans la gueule quoi
s'arrête chaud et fils petit gym jean
c'était sûr qu'il n'allait pas jouer la
finale de la tendresse contre avec cuba
qui y est tu peux pas jouer un truc
face aux grandes réserves mondiales
outre cramique peut-être pas contrebas
qui contrainte m ouais heureusement
qu'il est pas remplacé par kramnik
d'ailleurs là c'est en syrie la cata
flo7 escobar qui ont fait un petit des
trois ya de bonnes chances des retours
entre son mur ça sur un tourin may line
3,7 beeline de chez mainline c'est sûr
qu'il est une préparation acquis à baky
koné depuis qu'il est petit il joue et
ce avec les noirs pendant longtemps
c'est un jour de marshall avec les
blancs il connaît très bien fait mais
bon ok évidemment quinzaine connais bien
aussi ce que tu penses qu'il a revu la
vidéo de la drogue comme ça ne va qui
tua pour s'imprégner
c'est un mec lambda on annonce sa gueule
et voilà nice un peu nonchalant nokia il
propose enfin il se garde l'option du
marshall quoi on se maquille la peur du
marshall ou pas peur non ça sent surtout
fait nul mais
est ce qu'il va faire 1 h 4 1 cas de le
dire mais ma vie l'a fait à quatre
pattes marshall narbonne marshall ici il
essaye de se rappeler mais là c'est sûr
qu'il savait les deux qui serait cette
position en fait oui donc pas magnus je
veux dire la manif
ouais il a dû réviser détroit et ça en
fait c'est qu'il va faire espagnol et
rennes bat nice est déjà sous les doigts
déjà en avoir marre je prends quand même
pas acquis pendant dix heures il te fait
à 4 il te fait très mal quoi bon ok
juste pour n'est plus débutants à quatre
ils essaient de menacer sa donc en
général et nord soit ils poussent sous
les enlève la tour et voilà sinon d'en
coller deux à quatre l'autre option très
joué c c 3po c'est de prendre le centre
mais sur ces trois salles et sommesous
en noir de mettre solution ici sacrifier
un pion c'est ça qu'on appelle le granby
marshall et c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué mais c'est un jeu correct au
noir bien évidemment et bomba et qui du
coup avec sa base il empêche un peu mais
ba qui n'a pas eu l'air de marquer un
temps d'arrêt dans l'ouverture c'est
comme s'il avait décidé si espagnol qui
jouerait ça en fait oui après je sais
pas si c'était spécial pour la housse et
sa prépa du tournoi comme se dit comme
il a joué quatre tout le tournoi il a
normalement il sait ce qu'ils jouent
surtout vous quoi enfin sur la
socialiste qui fait si sûr si on à
petrov et de marie-laure son truc c'est
parce qu'assez carlson qui réfléchit le
premier dans ce match mal autant est ce
que tu penses qu'il peut tomber car le
risque qu'une arme à 929 pour 30 combats
qui se barre pour la grande marche c'est
parti fraga baky qui se dit qu il a fait
mal il a pu partir à temps mais voilà il
lui fait mal
oui je lève sur le coup on réfléchit en
face de moi je me bats je suis le
président élu il ne connaît pas à 4
vraiment incroyable et essaye de jouer
quoi il se dit oui mais je dois
absolument réagir arrive à qui revient
et regarde je suis pas loin il peut sa
petite bouteille parterre bien le 13 il
est bien le prez parce que ya pas une
caméra la cia pas une cam sur le presque
pendant qui marche ailleurs on regarde
un peu le le joueur norvégien issue
à lombez la cua c'est beaucoup
on dirait des endroits différents
suivant mais sur la came l'angle mesure
issue 1 gagny ça sent le saumon fumé à
magnus en sueur face au président le
foot bessette d'un coup pas bon alors
c'est un coup c'est déjà mieux que 3 8
mai
mais en fait je ne trouvais de ton avhc
pas qu'on fasse on fait des quatre ils
vont jouer que d'étroites ont fermé et
faire qu'à laisser trop de ça mais voilà
priori ça peut être interdit de faire
flamber 7 mais bon non c'est plus + b 4
quoi quand même le coup banis des genres
théorie non mais j'ai mené 1-4
c'est bien bon choix très bon choix
je pensais gueiler peut-être un des
premiers à organiser ça vraiment mais la
cam qu'est ce que c'est que ça
j'en vois qui atteint leurs parents
comme fixings nous montrer le joueur
iranien n a pas le magnifique c'est
qu'enfin surprise de baky bâches pour
aller à quatre c'est une surprise c'est
une surprise quoi c'est mais ce n'est
pas le seul des sept moines n'avaient
pas l'air d'être impressionné par fuchs
est mon prochain mmo mais tu connais où
je vous regardez moi je pense un coup je
ferai des trois-croix tranquille je
défends mon sens du but gagnant ses
trois géants dessin qui publie a été
mieux jouer encore beaucoup de parties
dans la micro base là tu as des trois
grands coups plutôt mon score blanc
gamme
il essaye de mettre bakker prépa qui va
te faire des trois tempo
non pas ces trois maintenant tout d'être
un des trois pour un peu l'envers cela
grünfeld pour faire le centre contre le
fou oui affiché un peu quand même pour
faire semblant qu'on attend sur un
carrousel il joue vraiment bien ces
positions fab un make-up paf détroit à
toi de jouer magnus
allez y réfléchit baky qui pue le
charisme martel qui en fait les plus
charismatiques que michael soit bas qui
malheureusement tu sens sa présence
quand même sur l'échiquier
après ce aussi ses fonctions de
président qui se ressentent un à la
caméra des six jouets bon régime ntic 3
même si probablement ya d'autres
possibilités
je ferais bien un petit cheval c3 quoi
ça serait beau qui lui envoie un livre
stratégie dans l'espagnol ou quoi après
rino en alpha échec avec good book
stratégie de rue lopez licha peas i've
had not value 10 une longue diagonale de
spend the spanish dit fans pour qu'ils
font fort qu'il sait trousser sérieux
sur les enfants l'espagnol pour les
enfants un fils d dos rond qui peut
partir en asymco parfois n'y a pas de
clause yacine qu il est très bien
préparée du coup tempo un très beau et
lui ouvre un gagner aux élus aux
fringues agneaux échec après very good
book l'auto film prouve min avec son
accent mythique vague ou de paper
quality c'est vrai ils se relaient
l'isba a failli connais tout ce qui fait
là bas qu'il est bien quand il connaît
bien tu ne m'a pas surpris je n'ai pas
assez bien préparé contre moi c'est du
valais havre est ce possible que vous
allez parler de foot des deux dans une
vidéo dans cette position même je sais
pas si cela ou une autre une autre met à
parler d'un fou des deux bateaux sont
fous des deux sites moi j'étais pas là
en fait mais c'était caruana qui est
sortie ça rognon 2018 mais c'était pas
là mais c'était un fou des deux un peu
étrange à première vue que tu as écrit
8e de finale ces quarts de finale attend
aurait pu mettre cas quarts de finale
avant leur finale au journal avant le
vrai mais hier le huitième de maxime
contre karine c'était vraiment une sorte
de 9 ans la sorte quoi mais quand même
étienne diniz en route vers le but de
strohl de marche et aux stratégies avec
dix joueurs bas qui cette année
l'énergie terrestre et la ba oui
largement largement à ce réseau il joue
contre qu'accros en finale bach rocha
crockwell finale tant attendue
ces voiliers ludique le stream anglais
s'est fait bad kids baqouba est plus
gros et que le truc c'est fort vis-à-vis
il paraît qu'on dépasse de docker johann
tschopp mais c'est fou parce qu'en fait
ils ont voit enfin des moyens incroyable
ils ont juste des faits les moyens c'est
enfin c'est juste qu'il ya deux ou trois
mille vies heures automatique
personne ne regarde for help c'est fou
quand même
c'est complètement fou bah kid et mons 1
qui n'ont pas un président à temps je
vais voir s'il ya pas la calme sur le
président nous orange à nicolas dodier
va comme cam différents voire leur
tronche à tous bam l'y pousse un pion h
on s'en fout mais juste il a envoyé quoi
ces batailles grèce et l'irlande c'est à
n'y rien alors les menus très chaude
oui il réfléchit à foncer karecki non il
a complètement la dette dans les mains
sans gloire ce que fait la chante là en
fait on un peu pour la chan que la cua
regarde très bien préparé la chanteuse a
enfin trouvé tempo quand t'as pas de
talent tu dois travailler
je vais tout est cool mais c'est
beaucoup quoi ça pas des rouches ont vu
mes bons frais mais bon ça ils jouent
tous tempo quoi il est bien quoi lâche
en khl la chante ludivine est là et sa
barbe et le petit ange
le psig anges moi je suis pour le petit
gange mais j'aime bien visite fin août
est sympa mais des savoirs est arrivé
recul il est gentil viande et pour
visiter un peu aussi quand même 20
minutes à lévis non mais il a l'air cool
sympa et marrant est sympa il est joyeux
il très jovial non c'est un peu le
faudel des échecs indien coi tu sais un
peu comme ce modèle vient déjà bien
visite mais tout aussi j'aime bien et
bon vivant et plus fourmi dite est un
méchant c'est pour tabataba est champion
vie dit eva qui en fait elle pour les
petits lots a sonné pour les surprises
et ta bouteille il a envie h4 comment
juste pour ça c'est pas la même chose si
je sais tout quoi m et abattent avait
revu ce truc c'est que délire dont la
pâle bonne iranien silva aux candidats
le délire il va douves était vraiment
dire fait plus qu'un nom mais c'est fou
toujours suis toujours dit quoi je
voudrais devenir français il est resté
iraniens ils veillent aux candidats fin
ce serait beau fois ce serait beau ou
pas d'ailleurs mais à notre gros plan
aïe aïe aïe complexe pour magnus qui
portent pas son badge en a aussi
peut-être réclamations possible du freud
ah oui parce que c'est ce que sa
accrédités ou pas je ne sais pas il
c'est fou toutes les têtes d'affiché
sont tombées il ne reste plus que baky
baril
wes a su côté côté magnus face à la
préparation est ce que tu veux que je
regarde sur sur la msi ben voyons petit
coup msi quoi bâtir une autre en guinée
messieurs aimait site quoi mais bon bah
qu'il a une turbine à massy dans chaque
parent très bien foutu reviennent de
partout
ouais je sais bien alors on veut un peu
une installation corner task des
directions de chasse base voire pauvre
papa je suis très très bien fait le seul
défaut cette chaise comme ki moon en a
chaque fois de me connecter avec ça me
fait perdre du temps mais a sinon très
bien
dire sa fin du coup de turbine est qui
part à forme humaine est juste la
première utilisation se perdre sur un
peu de temps viendra t lancée après je
suis lancé non c b 4e grand coup ça
ouais moi je me sens bien je donne des
sept dames 17 et les mauvais scores bkc
grand coup il le sait forcément mais il
a peur de la private bank qui je pense
est là une question sur b4 et j'ai bougé
les pieds de moi je sais pas j'espère à
500 connaître juste comme ça pour pas
que l'eau small faces et mes sept pions
b4 comme ça il se trouve que le mail cc3
mais à 5 peu faisait à 5 qu'est ce qui
se passe du tour b 8 mai pour pouvoir
défendre leurs conneries et là
bizarrement je bouge davantage c'est fou
c'est un fou c'est un roi c'est beau tu
veux pas le mettre ailleurs jugé sain et
couché mais elle a en fait mauvaise
nouvelle pour magnus
ouais y'a des gars qui ont analysé ya
pas longtemps profondeur 50 quand même
selon qui ça n'a jamais été joué à un
haut niveau
c'est un bond à l'idée j'imagine ce
livret à la caisse des deux pour mais
bon je suis pas sur quels points assez
fort assez qu'une turbine ya personne
qui l'a fait gamme ben ouais mot qui
peut faire et l'autre coup et l'autre
quoi le tout c'est ainsi n'ont cessé 3
ou h3 et h3t pour l'impression flux de
b4 donc ça serait une option et l'autre
si ces trois champions prend pions pan
attends attends bouge pas
bougez pas bouge pas
alors ça c'est une partie mvl
tomaszewski puis en france et 3 es là tu
es fou prend ces trois du pont du fou ah
oui c'est ça avec les idées d'envoyer
d'aidé quattro et des carrières et de
keisha ceci débile non c'est pas c'est
jouable aussi doivent être conservés 1,3
et de loin le meilleur score c'est fou
prend ces trois genres de très loin et à
ivan ljubicic
ah oui non à leonardo lubich
malheureusement bien bien moins bon
service
non mais en vrai quoi penser 3 1 il ya
du tout rabais 8 qui est bd de aussi
dans des parties par correspondance bon
de se battre
trouver de b4 c3 puis on prend fou prend
ses trois tours du but qui avait des
deux pouces et 8 pouces et 4 tu as un
mec qui a gagné sa part correspondance
quand même une pression sur un servat
l'idée set à 5-6 cavaliers afin battu le
défense qui a hissé ce cavalier 5 et 3g
si ce qui a aidé 5 il a défoncé en fait
ça se fait par correspondance s'est
ainsi pu faire ça il va dégager sata une
pression en navarre tas de petits dés
quattro qui peut arriver à tout moment
il a complètement défoncé en fait non
mais là c'est une très bonne chose de la
part des nord oui mais bon c'est parfois
c'est que ça doit pas être facile en
fait est ok deuxième question c'est 3 à
qu'est-ce qui se passe tu veux c'est 3 à
5 6 à quoi l'histoire pas les changer
complexe en fait il ya peu de parties
nos turbines et non des 4èmes c'est ma
logique créé 17 qui avait 17 sur des 4
alors il ya plus de parti mais du coup
la turbine propose de faire h3 champions
le 6 juin les pièces un peu et des cinq
caisses des choses en face je sais pas
si on est bien et français 3e français
3d tremblay prend way cahier où cet
oubli beach n'a peut-être kbit histoire
de mettre un kabyle à l'autre la veille
des tests in full 3 10 sur wii blanc
cassis fait cavalier à trois cavaliers
c5 way est fou c'est 2-1 visuellement
j'ai présenté mon père et je comprends
que plus te dire bon piqué c4 je vis ça
te gêne kazan b5
j'ai peut-être m'installer qui sait ça a
été analysé par le prez de devenir lui
échangé sa son truc
4 ok bon on a vu un peu sauvage qu'on
peut s'attendre on verra c'est fou comme
la ps2 car assène un bond au ps je sais
pas mais
j'ai envie de dire bah qui est en train
de lui montrer qui est le chef d
ouverture déjà enfin on disait bamba qui
est ce que c'est un bon second dans pour
maxime ou quoi parle on va que la prépa
de baky elle met en danger
l'autoproclamé numéro un mondial pagé
roquette a jamais battus baky en match
doudou nous tous les jours on a toujours
de quoi en fait
serais-tu selon champion de france
je ne pense pas même le pakistan avec
six habitants n'aura jamais le titre
c'est beaucoup avec histoire n'est pas
champion préromane territoire c'est
juste une maison et un barbecue derrière
c'était quand même derrière
pas de chance peut-être un peu plus fort
que nikita la chienne de terre-neuve de
bas qui est plus fort que le teckel de
bakkies botha magnus c'est le seul que
tu vas y si quoi vous elle serait beau
canal tecate avec lui ce qui vient il
joue à fond à quoi bon
champion du monde sauf baky c'est beau
ça baky koné vainqueur la piste rim'k
pas l'année dernière j'avais bien que
c'est un gros tournoi c'est ça qui
relance tout de suite ce qui attend le
vacarme la bitstream quai puis en quart
de finale de coupe du monde quand on va
chez moi c'est quand même un beau tour
en bas ça c'est tout chaud froid de
vieux comte robert s
ah ben non mais n'empêche ça a été plus
fort que saltimbanques nice tour un bon
fait il ya plein de mcnish tour où il ya
aucun des joueurs du manis tour que l'on
qui sont en quarts de finale actuel et
avec magnus
mais même face où il ya participé ils
jouent pas tout le temps mais non mais
non épargnants aronian qui a gagné
certains magnus tournoi
il apparaît au premier tour la coupe du
monde mais comment tu fais c'est quand
même assez faible comme tournoi c'est
une cup a encore en quarts non mais mon
taratata il n'a pas participé à chanter
à participer pas faim lassus prend tous
les quart de finalistes duda il en a
joué l'hymne je crois mais dit aussi
fait de cf non car yakine non plus en
quoi il pourrait jouer le sprint cup
peut-être way ci pourra être invité à y
réfléchir les enfants n'est plus moi
j'ai pas assez bossé merde
il y avait une tension de colonnes on
[Rires]
peut plus grave à ses valeurs notamment
à l'heure de profonds quoi ça me choque
la sphère kireev trois là je crois que
ce soit qui les feront cinq robots nul
coffin
on remet la cam de fixe pour la sueur
dégoulinait attendues lé pourquoi elle
tombe pas plus vite c'est une 26 sa mère
très peu quoi une fois qu'il est en
train de jouer même si mes refresh quoi
tu n'as plus tendues et baky en ce
moment il est sur le stand de alpha edge
et xhaka à sotchi
si vous voulez acheter des échiquiers ou
quoi c'est le moment je crois qu'à des
promos à -25% pendant le pendant tout
son match contre magnus
entre deux coups ouais avec le code 2d
25 125 % après pour vraiment les
connaisseurs il ya le code saumon fumé 1
à ses quarante 40 % mais ça faut être
connaissez vous le trouverez qu'ici
smoke solomon empêche les gens qui ont
les livres dédicacés par ba qui doit
être très heureux d'y casser par le prez
alcott sushi ne marche pas non non non
tu pourrais prendre des sushis de saint
jacques ou des sushis de tons foncés pas
trop tu as donc d'après yves cochet de
saint jacques
non pas du tout non non j'ai pris un
lover plateau mais à l'ovaire de
moi-même qui intrigue à partager mais
comme il n'est pas si gros le truc je
viens juste 24 pièces qui avait failli
vous qui connaissez pas qui n'est ce pas
trop au lieu de jouer des parties face à
des joueurs bien plus faible que lui
comme carl rsa et qui peu après il est
venu faire les parties pédagogique sur
la chaîne et tout donc il s'échauffe et
moi je peux s'est bâti
[Rires]
j'ai reçu les professionnels en cadeau
dans une commande avec la dédicace du
prez bas il se fait chier quand même là
c'est beaucoup quoi ameuter les plaisirs
en fait quand son adversaire a fléchi
ouais bah tu te fais chier un peu vos tu
marches enfin tu gagnes un concours de
marche et en plus aux échecs étudie à
bayal autant je pars je vais vite je
mette la pression donc tu es très
heureux q quelles sont les prochaines g
science pour mvl pour une qualification
aux candidats oui mais bon ça est
question ne se pose fabre allied hoffman
bain la prochaine séance ça tournoi mode
open pour les plus de 2600 et je sais
pas je crois qu'ils les deux premiers
sont qualifiés ça voilà au cas où au cas
où cas où il y aura des grands prix fidh
plus tard ce sera quand je pars en
octobre par un octobre je crois je
connais pas les dates exactes à ce que
bakili à bischwiller pas du tout au long
de ma vie au pakistan y vit au pakistan
si ce temps dans le sud de la france
c'est pas son coup je ne peux pas passer
il pourra entendre la bonne suite par
inadvertance derrière de renseignement
fait ce débat je veux son jeu dame 17
sais pas pourquoi c'est beau quoi va qui
avait fait la prépa pour maxime et qui
la place puis quoi n'empêche ça prouve
que tout le monde le dit depuis les way
la world cup c'est magnus qui fait
l'audience étouffé en attendant on est
huit mille cinq cents pour baky ouais
ils sont 6800 en faisant les fonds de
tiroir enfin en et ils sont plutôt 4000
en organique le nom c'est baky qui fait
l'audience de cette coupe du monde
non mais gère françois est bien d'accord
l'audience c'est baky enfin si les gens
sont en réalité ce couillon de c'est que
pour baky qua non mais tu voir que si
baky éliminé aura beaucoup moins là-bas
au niveau de l'an prochain boss que ce
qu'il faudrait continuer à faire bah non
c'est trouve immonde aura-t-elle encore
un intérêt quoi c'est pour s'envoyer pas
la cam sur baky
c'était quand même étonnant scandale
chaise comme l'espagnol 187 personnes
pour voir bas qu'ils allaient y voit la
chanteuse vient pas si on tourne à non
il regarde la caméra de championne de la
partie de baqaa il voulait faire
cavalier à 5,5 les espagnols prophylaxie
faux pas qui est tombé à 5 et la fille
des russes aussi regardent manu silva
ils comprennent comme food et 2,20 fou
pour être pas quoi faire et roscoff il
regarde la chante là parce que c'est
leur joueur en face
ouais ils sont 250 enfin on les écrase
qu un bas qui les écrase et les polonais
regarde duda cependant un grand choix
ouais ouais les américains il regarde
quoi ya un gars de champclos on chante
là on va dire que nous ont vécu sur bas
qui ont hélas nous reste ce soit au
royaume quoi pensez-vous comme ceux des
deux seuls
ça lui a fait mal fait réfléchir en tout
cas maximon sueur qui sait que c'était
sa prépa compte magnus et qui voit le
prez la passe et refaire d'autres
époques un système à deux façons je
pense que maxime et il a autorisé à baky
tout et n'importe laquelle de ses vrais
parents chemin il a carte blanche au bas
qui serait beau come back qui est m vélo
candidats bah oui le rêve ça va truc il
tournera 2-0 bon voilà je vais vraiment
parents pour enfants contre mvl comme
tous les autres très bien
je ne fais pas du chat noir pour avoir
mis bas kibaki bas qui dérive de john de
hou shike amauri suspendu
en fait il va vraiment vite tu vas enfin
nous ont réussi à gérer des tchats avec
8000 personnes seraient quasiment zéro
ban et ed que des coups tordus baky du
requin est tous à sa balle à tour de
bras ces normes et des émeutes
ouais non il n'aime pas trop les nôtres
non plus ils sont très tristes qu'enfin
mais c'est pour ça qu'ils aient par son
regard boisson est là bas aussi tu
éduques accroc aujourd'hui tu peux te
faire ban quoi oui mais non mais ça
s'éduque accros du sap america courait
truite vous là par contre tu peux mettre
du cac crocs sur le czech comme ça pour
ba qui va bien sûr tout sauf sociaux il
va de vote pour ba qui coiffe un format
ministre pour cent c'est beau quoi les
gens sont plus là pour ne pas regarder
les géo que pour regarder magnus quand
même assez beau y ait eu des gages pour
allez la france
c'est terrible mort ou alors que moi
l'autre jour quand il ya un raid
d'indiens j'étais super heureux quand il
écrit des trucs d'indiens étaient
heureux voix juste et la fin sounalet
comme avec et enfin le gange coiffant le
gange qui vient j'étais très heureux
mais généralement ils sont assez hostile
après tout ce qu'on a une communauté
très toxiques qu'ils je vois les gens
qui te battre toxiques à la france perd
2-0 japon étant au foot mais on est
vraiment nulle quoi les que gignac est
encore ça veut dire beaucoup que
purifiée par le crash
ce serait terrible
quelques visites qui viennent sur un
live et qui boivent un verre du gange
les tableaux du gange et envoie un petit
peu vache il très bon pour les défenses
immunitaires ya qu'eux
gnac la tristesse de ce constat mais
c'est bon tout va je crois que vous
n'importe comment et nordin est quand
même bon je suis étonné à la réflexion
de ma nièce il ya longtemps que vraiment
une demi-heure déjà web ont un dossier
de comprendre les petites nuances ou
illégaux ont dépassé par la puissance je
pense crif commenter mais il se doit
sentir l'énergie terrestre le sujet mais
comment tu peux comprendre les nuances
de baxi en fait ces cinq ambiances de
baky on a gagné saillie l'essai mais tu
n'y arriveras pas bon que tu cliques au
hasard et c'est moi qui va toujours au
hasard mais il explique à l'analyse
après faillite du club 10 to fail click
to buy chen chen mo slip to play my
nightmare bon ben bishop de eden hazard
dido and the things eden hasard fait
bien les choses enfin dr guen thorgan
hazard 50 nuance de baky je m'agite
terrestrials energy quoi alors ce power
bike qui l'a pas du tout valider un an
ba terrestrials à la rigueur tu dis of
cuir l'énergie quoi mais tu peux pas je
vais garder quand même d'aider du
français quoi du franglais dans le truc
pas qui a perçu à yokohama pour voir les
gif ou quoi dubaï qui a faire sur le
stade pour les médailles les câbles
voiture la connexion d'un clic et
j'attends les oreilles être que baky
signer des autographes actuellement à
l'entrée du médecin
tu es l'escale ça se dit en anglais bien
sûr que ça si tu as dit c'est mondiale
en vedette les joueurs en même temps ça
qu'il va chanter landes
oui c'est nantes aligne j'aurais dû
faire ça chante là le cha secourus ont
veillé par l'abbé ap vous étiez mais
richert de quoi jusqu'à bruce j'ai pas
ils sont tous partis suivent et après je
vous engueuler en plus gens disent ouais
machin vous allez partout non mais ça me
retombe dessus on vous a fait ses
conneries vous en revanche vous fait de
l'audience c'est bien qu'après 10 ou à
vous les français vous d'être loué on
était 50 et 13 ont été mes rêves non
plus et à ce petit jeu qui mérite en
sueur jean vidal et aussi savoir chat
même des trucs assez taille critique
ceux qui commentent à cette oeuvre a
fait est annoncée à karlovy on veut voir
le prix stagnent ou mais mes sauts très
chaud c'est bien rock terrible c'était
ribemont fab équipe bâtie en cyrillique
ils font n'importe quoi non moi lors de
cette édition
rien sinon oui sinon il n'y avait rien
avancer rixe a rendu leur chat vivant
passe avec cet ouvrage fait traiter de
tricheur ce que j'avais des fours ça je
suis une croix rappelle avait fait une
lettre à thiès comme une lettre ouverte
et tous ces gens se foutent de ma gueule
et tout oui c'est impossible qui joue de
tels coups après avoir causé par g4
enfin gérard brut et niveau
c'est pourquoi quand même fait le traîte
de tricheur je sais pas jouer dans mes
toiles et 25 fidh s'est pas même pas
s'il est de 1500 m annoncez votre
sûrement très faible
en plus je viens si je connais yal de
doute on voit des lettres comme ça de
dénonciation cheville 24 70 pourquoi tu
joues qua non mais ça semble qu'il y ait
un jus dance encore un mec j'ai jamais
dans aucun temps donc on devra nulle
part non mais les pas méchant pour la
peine mmm est revenue par contre je vois
pourquoi faire un énorme ils étaient
vexés d'avoir perdu contre une robe du
coup il à la tilt mais moi je n'y peux
rien si tu t'es nul en fait non mais
c'est pas de ma faute
ça arrive ces sorties allumer le
barbecue mais vers la côte de zapper
côte bleue c'est un troll non non
c'était pas un troll sa lettre ouverte
c'était vraiment pour me faire band of
joy scops exceptionnel riche c'est bon
pour la russie il dit l'aimer écrivant
en russe les meilleurs somme on ne nage
pas à la surface au pakistan voilà un
truc comme ça j'ai pas eu le temps de
tout lire à sebha kibaki bas qui dresse
et mac imac et mac et bikey président
enfin ses raisons
magnus prend autant de temps bas c'est
vraiment parce que la prépa de ba qui
lui fait mal enfin c'est vraiment ça on
réalise les affiches chef ou des deux je
fais b4 machin il évalue calcul loin est
ce que je fais jordan 17
vous êtes ridicules et 8 k -o 6e
rebondir à ce que je fais je sais pas
quoi il a joué assez de quoi peut-être
d'hommes descendeur bonsoir j'ai pas
trop vu pas kibaki bas qu'il a mis dès
tout petit temps je vais tarifs fresh md
set je sentais qu'ils redonnent des
soldes j'ai envie de te dire va te dire
ici un tel nom mais je sais pas ce sont
2,5 ou car ce n'est ce qu'un homme de
cette je sais je sais pas c'est un
maquillage le thème pourquoi les plus
personnalisable et ces trois points pour
les séparer je vais marcher en fait mais
c'est magnifique de faire ça il est venu
il à thème que jpp comme acquis qui gît
en tête rousse contact avec ton pions b5
céline numéro leur a bien évidemment le
temps il est pas trop le temps de
traîner parce que peut la retourner la
côte de boeuf non mais c'est bien parce
que l'autre se lève il repère de trois
minutes
le teint hâlé déjà plus qu'à 58 minutes
car le sable entre dia et encore deux
trois coups comme ça et tu tombes quoi
ils jouent bien en tout cas pour le bon
bah tiens vous parfait la lettre
mère de carlson qui après c'est beaucoup
1h04 mais qui ont cette chance car ses
34 ouais c est qu un petit bug femmes
nées des parties voyez encore des
parties à plein de partis encore à l'eba
qui ya andersen qui a joué ça ça rime
avec karl scène en bundesliga se fait
défoncer ces deux norvégiens de saumon
l'un contre l'autre
il s'est fait marcher dessus en fait
saumonade ger bat cahors se fait
défoncer en fait ça sent pas bon
mais je pense que je t'aime pour
l'allemagne où il a joué déjà c'est
parce qu'il fait des crédits truc
parce que ceux autorisés le masque sur
la table non je pense pas éliminatoire
il écrit bas qui dans son best fat bon
c'est fantastique où il joue et qui a
laissé trois tempo il réfléchit il est
dégoûté commerçants j'ai voulu éviter la
prépa fatigue née tout quoi face à une
machine en face de moi c'est c'est le
pakistan va c'est le prez arrière quand
il est sucré on peut plus voir super
heureux de son adoption de chasse comme
au rugby qui n'est vraiment pas
impressionné et j'ai encore une première
petite pub fab on doit terrible on est
obligé à céder 6 minutes en trois
minutes
ouais je sais mais cinq minutes de votre
enfant ait fait deux fois trois maîtres
g de farine 3 hier 3 min
c'est l obligation pour avoir les calmes
quoi brassant été dommage de pas voir le
saumon suez vraie question
à l'instant c'est comment qu'on bouge le
cheval déjà preuve qu'il y bâtissent
trois blessés vaut quand même d'être
devenu le pays au monde qui suit le plus
aisés m parce qu'en fait flop
donc allez tu auras d'échec on est tous
là et faudrait beaucoup plus nombreux
que tous les autres pays ont dit on fait
de la merde qu'enfin on est bien mais
c'est incroyable en fait de vie vraiment
le pays leader des échecs dans le monde
comme un incroyable
en ce cas personne derrière baky un vin
qui n'est pas là qu'il s'est relevé mais
c'est bien que magnus et réfléchie c'est
vraiment tellement positif ça peut le
fasi un peu ouais on voit vraiment créé
le club d'échecs du pakistan soit un
jour ils seraient licenciés
extraordinaire français ou un club à qui
cette année mais comment on fait discret
où il fait coopération vague style des
échecs vous crée vraiment un truc vision
fait fort et qu'elle soit affilié à la
fij et la financière est avant tout -
qui veulent s'inscrire obligé de faire
la fb de coopération mexès des échecs
avec son président et du divin qui
etienne bacrot élus l'opposition etienne
cas croatie toujours c'est très
démocratique et à maquereau iliaque
accroc et aussi la fkl notre adversaire
fération quelque 16 des échecs ça
traversèrent ultime quoi fait de propre
aux olympiades nous compétition pakistan
kaki 100e derby way est voté on va
déséquilibrer un piano et là on suit aux
olympiades
enfin vous l'objectif ultime finir
devant le kaki ce temps nous aimons 157
pays représentés c'est à la fille de
nouveaux records avec l'introduction du
kaki story by qui se tend j'aurais
tellement faire c'était possible serait
tellement beau mais peut-être si
possible de faire sans fait genre en
suisse dont la fédération genevoise des
échecs et ils ont plusieurs fédérations
des voix donc voilà pourquoi pas monter
la fédération bas qui se tenait ce que
ça a été un magnifique
fâcheux une île pour créer le baptiste
28 ans cotisent pas le bac qui cogne ce
serait magnifique avec une tête de
bakchich comme vous pouvez le comprendre
si vous êtes nouveau à suivre les échecs
comme les parties sont longues en fait
on part souvent dans des délires parce
que sinon on fait sèchement à temps 48
pour jouer pour voir deux coups donc au
bout d'un moment il y à un bain de
l'antenniste qui se crée autour le bas
qui dort enfin cours ce matin j'ai
acheté du second haut fourneau sion est
ce un hasard je ne crois fra ont dit ce
qu'ils racontent à quoi il est donc bien
apparemment ouais pourquoi il parle du
pakistan il parlait de bayti ou quoi je
sais pas ça il ya maxime qui m'écrit
maxime tu va nous rejoindre ok superbe
et résiste vous laisse je vais beaucoup
havre à la plage as-tu à la plage place
avec 9 h pas bon mais venu mais je
reviendrai prix n'est pas très contente
par avec maxime mais en fait je sais pas
je trouvais 3 comme ça ouais mais bon
comme on estime sais pas si tu vas pas
comme tu veux tu as la plage c'est
différent je voulais y aller un moment
vu 10 à 15 heures je vais y aller et
comme ces 14h47 et que je laisse pas
tout seul comme tu le sens en tout cas
bas qui joue l'un cavaliers à 5 et je
crois qu'il a joué déjà non il a déjà
joué
je revois
attends je vais à 60 real temps qu'il
arrive quoi atteint la minute de la
nager avec les dauphins
c'est avec ak n'ya pas de sots bons noms
et des dauphins et des requins à ça à
temps est-ce que j'ai tout qui est bien
et a rejoué tempo en fait même une fois
deux ouais bon en même temps turquie à 5
entre potes laisser bouffer oui mais bon
c'est bien c'est quand même tempo c'est
quand même tempo est si pépé ya un site
web sur le bas qui sort bah oui pakistan
c'est quoi qui sont très fermes ont
peut-être point point b cas où un truc à
wim effacés ces congrès que ça va être
aph
ça va devenir un pays quoi même une
radio enfin je sais pas mais il ya plein
de trucs en fait mais je repasse vous
voir dans un moment j'ai juste tu va
plonger plonger un peu puis pas très
longtemps comme le soleil va mettre des
coups de soleil donc avant que ça arrive
ça déjà revenue à mais tu prends pas le
téléphone sur mon téléphone je reste pas
longtemps que c'est juste histoire de
presse ordinaire gbagbo tu veux tu peux
suivre le live en fait yes vue sur je me
suis pas qu'il ya tout un débat qui bat
kibaki baky à toute femme on a fait un
petit coup de régis genre un peu au
centre monte attend de pied ferme
prépare toi quoi alors on attend maxime
qui va arriver lui aussi on attend
reffouh a deux c'est ce dont on avait
parlé avec fab c'est ce dont on avait
parlé avec fab mag liste continue à peu
à réfléchir en train de préparer le
cieux pour arriver de max
maxime qui est l'âme écoute ya maxime
qui arrive qui doit être acquis doit
tout à quai et bonjour à toi max y est
c'est lui alors je rajoute packham
et voilà on est partis genre elle c'est
un gros jour de fête aujourd'hui un ba
ouais mais là attention parce que
pendant que un an ça y est c'est ouais
bah c'est bien ça moi je viens de voir
que etienne vient de sortir de la
piscine de l'hôtel
il repart à la salle de jeu ça va tu es
en forme à écoutent oui et non mais
surtout oui aujourd'hui parce que
j'imagine que ça tu as mis du baume au
coeur quand même devoir était de se
qualifier tu te mettras voir ça bien sûr
surtout qu'après le premier à pied de
wes et elle n'était pas forcément mieux
mais newey mais c'est passé puis la prof
écoute on y croit à fond je te félicite
quand même on reviendra plus là dessus
mais pour pour ta compet ce que tu as
quand même à tu as quand même pas mal
joué je trouve c'était cool donc avant
web voyait beaucoup de mieux après je
suis déçu huawei mais voilà il ya des
prochains tournois donc falloir comme
temps de gamberger
non il va falloir aller chercher le
présent parce que il ne veut pas du coup
d'état apparemment à chaque fois que tu
es dans un tournoi je le ferai si les
bouillants ouais là tu en penses quoi
alors que la balle après pas savoir de
cette plutôt bien passé et visuellement
en tout cas moi mais l'audi no cry chine
réfléchit après ses cinq bougies
magiques et des cinq en fait simplement
ici vos biscuits situer le cavaliere à 5
sera toujours mal placée en fait
peut-être jusqu'à et dessins qui est un
des cinq qui devra s'efforcer pions font
donc un peuple cavale
ouais c'est quoi food et 8 ou b4 sur
food et 8 sur à duper quatre têtes y
apprend et b4
exemple ça c'est des gueules surement
ça c'est dégueu parce qu'en plus âpre f5
peut-être déjà du top 5
pardon du coup calais prend 1,5 et tous
qui enchaîne ouais je sais pas si ça
marche je monte l'idée quoi avec damage
5 et 6 et tous ok et tu peux jouer même
simplement parce que le cahier à 5 alors
je l'aï la plus de cases reviendra
jamais voilà et sinon donc si tu joues
b4 stand logique là je voulais c'est 3
ouais si je avec b3 tu avec foubert et
tu feras des 4 as oui ou alors c'est
bien ici et c'est 4 mai 4 non mais faut
bien c'est un coup aussi parce qu'en
fait tu as maintenant ou bien c'est pas
un coup il faut prendre des 5 c 4 3 3
c'est pas du tout un groupe
mais il faut prendre les trois oui tu
prends deux pions donc il peut pas faire
b3 il va faire payer à faire puis on
prend du coup mais en fait je pense que
tu dois faire b3 parce que puis en
france où prend foot et 8 dingue des
deux va fort pensez à appeler
l'ambulance de toute urgence
ah ça fait mal a avec le cavalier qui a
attaqué si je fais du dames c 'est tout
quoi ça va être un moment de suva jobé 4
km tu vas tout échanger tour s'adresse à
donner un truc comme ça
ouais c'est un tour bien et ça va faire
mal
yes owen là c'est donc en vrais caïds et
5 ça me semble être le coup quoi
peut-être il veut fou prendre des cinq
en fait voilà c'est ça qu'ils veulent
est hélas je voulais être dupes ou
prendre des 5
parce qu'en fait sur quels points des
cinq fours un dessin qui a peut-être
cassé 6 l'âge des 5
et puis on prend donc la cavalier c6 tu
reviens alors dans la soute à la perte
de fou
un peu comme hier entre piorun en
quelque sorte voilà ta la paire de foot
à étapes plus fous de cases blanches
c'est énorme en fait
et du coup c'est du bon foot franck est
prends je comprends son cran qui avait
les b sat ou b4 web et dans les deux cas
tu es mieux sur qui et bessède tu que tu
as le choix tu peux jouer ses cadres tu
peux jouer à cinq je jouais pas mal que
complètement l'enfermer à les enfermer
le canal quoi la mesa attention de still
image où elle s'incrit des huit grands
classiques du jouet repart de l'autre
côté hockey c'est pour ça que c'est
qu'être fan club des quatre mais pierre
français 4 et a5 et même des derrière du
coup tu bloques l'oeil dames et tu
repars avec lecavalier mais la tour
ronde et 8 r es tu fais mal où ces deux
ça doit être qu'ils déclinent des 5 vous
prendrez il a joué club a lieu de wale a
choqué au dos du coup aucun des cinq
n'est quand même pas un peu ennuyeux il
a calculé qu'un hyper vite non le prez
web après ses dépositions qui connaît
aussi sans doute
j'aime à l'air d'être en grande forme
ouais et e2 ouais ça c'était sain d'être
impossible pour le kg troqué f5 briques
août
oui les shows oui il était très chaud
voilà y'a pas d'autonomie jallet a
répondu il a vraiment l'air d'être dans
une grande forme comme je lui ai parlé
hier il avait l'air d'être d'être bien
quoi à domicile ils jouent à domicile
scène c'est un gros avantage mais il
kiffe les soleils anne k et tout va il
est vraiment très heureux tu vas au
repas il tout en tout sourire au web à
l'aso bien kate pas que parce qu'il n'ya
pas que de la solenca il y'a du y avait
quoi il hier qu'il est juif ohr show
assez bon ça comme soupe ça c'est très
bon en vrai il y avait d'ailleurs une
cali en fait on était dans un géorgien
j'ai compris quand j'ai senti avec un
quine cali c'est sûr ah c'est bon c'est
bon quand les jeux la cuisine géorgienne
quand c'est bien
cuisiner c'est fantastique ouais bien
sûr et qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent fiq
donc il s'est mis bien baki bah oui oh
bah de toute façon on n'a fait que se
mettre bien depuis le début de la
compote toi tu restes un petit moment
d'ailleurs non en web alors en fait la
question c'est quand je parte parce que
je dois aller directement aux us un fait
ça c'est le sais le truc je peux pas
passer par la france
bastien travel ban depuis la zone
schengen travail bref voilà travel
bender donc donc après on va voir avec
le prez un peu jusqu'à ce que jusqu'à
quand je reste au minimum jusqu'au 31
après sa belle en six qualifiés ou pas
en fait ouais bah après faudra aussi je
m'organise avec les organisateurs vu
qu'ils vont me faire venir aux yeux as
tu veux que je leur donne pas une date
et que je change ensuite au dernier
moment donc
après peut-être qu'on va rester quelques
jours en plus quoi qu'il arrive je sais
pas après je pense pas que je vais
rester jusqu'au bout ça ferait trop long
mais savez-vous de l'icwa au minimum
après ces jolies du coup la station la
sotchi écoute on se débrouille moi j'ai
pas trop mauvaise vue
ah ouais c'est sympa c'est un peu bête
un petit peu si tu peux je baisse autant
que possible non on a on a vu deux mais
voilà on voit nickel ah oui c'est joli
magnifique ah ouais non c'est sympa max
et s
c'est très sympa
vue sur les montagnes et tooway c'est
joli mais à être bon t'as pas pu faire
de randonnée j'imagine mais si un jour
le seul problème c'est ya trop sahel
alors dit je sentiers rôti et c'est le
prix à payer mais et du couserans donner
ça à était faisable sur à eau n'a pas
fait après on a beaucoup marché parce
qu'ils ont un petit peu on n'est pas
coté en plus du centre-ville avec les
restos donc on ne mange pas beaucoup le
soir après jour plus un des petits
trains donner tout mais ça me branche
pas spécialement non plus je viens a
beaucoup qui sont montés dans les
montagnes mais là je ferai un peu honte
aggravante a plus vu sur le ping pong un
maximum maxime qui a freeze l'ordinateur
qui chauffait pris part par la chaleur
je vais nique et une petite à une petite
coupure internet tu l'auras entend max
ouais je suis de retour
c'est connexion connaissions caquistes
annese à barika collection de l'hôtel
mais oui du coup je disais on t'a vu
jouer au ping pong
tu m'entends ouais je t'entends je
t'entends tu vas à l'eau et à tarbes
site d'un petit décalage est ouais ouais
je suis de retour
tu m'entends ouais mais je crois que tu
crois que tu es décalé maxime
je crois que tu as un décalage un décor
et je reviens aurait peut-être fait un
aller-retour à moins que tu m'entends tu
quand j'ai trois là trois on est un tout
petit décalage encore ok ok non mais là
je crois que j'ai plus de décalage ok
donc oui tu es la fille joue au ping
pong c'est ça c'est exactement ça on en
parle un petit décalage victime qui
était carré de la connexion de l'hôtel
en sueur banalité partage a tout de
suite max s'inquiète inquiète
ouais j'ai vu ce classeur régler
tranquillement le souci
décalé
les g3 ping pong le but avoué
mais défend maxime au ping pong a des
fois les connexions d'hôtel quand tu
commences à rien- des cages
il faut il faut redémarrer pour
l'instant c'est fou le premier en ligne
de leur dire oui mais je pense qu'il
connaît un petit peu à baky il a dû bien
se préparer
ça devrait fonctionner
ça devrait fonctionner ouais alors par
contre notre came way est ce qu'on peut
en fait ce qu'on peut ouais bah non
puisque dehors ça marche trop mal
internet d'airbus landi rôtissait donc
essayer de faire un retour dans la
chambre belles chambres d'ailleurs
confortable confortable par contre je
vais pas faire la simple de la chambre
c'est trop le bordel mais chambres
individuelles tranquille
oh bah oui non non je partage pas encore
ma chance ça on aurait pu le penser vu
tes activités sur les réseaux sociaux
j'étais obligé de tout roland petit peu
quand même
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe il ya des choses qui
sont postés
donc du coup le prez
il nous fait quoi examen qui a réalisé 3
way et g3 qui est un coin qui est un
coup comme un autre pour mètres le kili
5 donc là la question ça doit être des
cinq et on prend cavaliers francs et
qu'elle va les prendre cinq noms tu as
pris ses fruits si je suis magie
récupère b2 ok c'est chaud quand même ça
c'est super chaud parce que tu peux
jouer même un coup comme tourage 5
peut-être mais pense h ok il ya toujours
les question c'est qu'est ce que tu fais
après déchet 6 alors la iraqi de cannes
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être ça que
calcul d'ailleurs le saumon tu penses
qui prend comment le match
magnus contre contrebas qui sans grand
favori et il dit faut que j'assure et je
le bats facile où il prend baky très au
sérieux
ballet de il sait que c'est un quart de
finale après ils pensent naïvement être
le favori a conforté par le par le
classement est nommé tu n'es pas le
classement elle aux officiels en fait
cette place c'est pas de classement elo
batista n'est donc elle n'a aucune
valeur votre classe on va exister à
débat et qui d'ailleurs était le premier
et unique joueur à dépasser les 3000 1
voilà très clairement mais et baky en
plus il peut à mon avis même en rapide
doit pas avoir trop trop peur de magnus
etienne il est quand même en grosse
forme rapide j'ai trouvé très bon il a
été bon après bon magnus en rapide c'est
du costaud malgré tout donc
donc non je dirais un match équilibré
mais voilà petit avantage bas qui veut
que cette prépa elle passe quoi donc
donc il a bien mérité ses 98 % de deux
victoires sur le sondage
c'était beau le sondage choses comme
quand ils l'ont fait tu pouvais pas je
pense tu jouais à ce moment là ou pas
peut-être je sais plus mais c'est quand
y jouer contre pancrate of jusqu'à
maintenant je ne jouais pas avec je lui
prêtant l'a vu celui-là way for mac
oui et puis il y avait oui tu pouvais
voter à 900 en utilisant 989 points de
shell je vais pouvoir voter donc j'étais
penser tous mes points de chaîne c'est
beau ça bien qu'ils servent à quelque
chose
donc je crois qu'il est comme en fait
ils comprennent jamais sur leur live
tout d'un coup faim tout va bien tout se
passe comme prévu tout se passe comme
toujours et tout d'un coup et une
invasion
ouais bah d'ailleurs l'invasion
l'invasion continueront les envahit
encore aujourd'hui j'imagine mais en
fait pas de toute façon 50% milan viewer
sénou non quant à mia à paris quand on
en voit de toute façon là on fait
en termes de chiffres car on doit être
jugé là on est quatorze mille quoi ah
mais attends mais comment ils sont
montés à 22000 check point une première
page américaine donc en fait ça alors je
pense qu'ils ont quatorze mille
personnes qui sont un frein l'instant on
peut pas lutter en fait c'est impossible
là en fait non tu peux pas lutter parce
que il était il était à 7000 on était à
onze mille donc tu peux
il ya sans doute au moins dix mille
personnes en plus en fait je crois que
quand ils ont ça entre ce qu'ils ont sur
la page de duchess com qui fait beaucoup
de gens et ça je pense qu'en vrai ils
sont 4 5 milles mais bon enfin n on est
naturel à 13500 wayne on est bien là
pour le président ya du monde à après
moins de monde que pour toi au candidat
quand même il faudra le rappeler au
président candidat oui mais attention
postule y aura les candidats 2022 avec
plusieurs éléments français peut-être à
ça serait tellement beau ça serait
tellement beau ça les éléments belle
gitane mm à la magnus magnus qui sur un
j'y crois j'y crois de plus en plus ces
écoutes il lui reste 42 minutes baky qui
vous tous tempo mais comment ça tu y
crois de plus en plus ça veut dire que
tu croyais pas assez au début enfin j'y
croyais à 97% au début là je suis à 99
fois de plus en plus je prends des pour
soi voilà oui c'est ce que c'est comme
ça donc kg trois dessins comme tu disais
si ça passe c'est logique un bon ça doit
être ça calcule parce que sinon
cavaliers vient à f 5 c'est quand même
très désagréable oui le x 2 qui va taper
à long terme et à toutes les pièces qui
vont arriver sur son roi surtout qu en
fait un des plans des noirs dans ses
positions normalement ces deux jeux des
4 pour ensuite jouer b3 et coupé le fou
de caisse blanche
mais là tu peux plus le coupé le foot
guesh blanche avec le pur en c2 ça va
être impossible un retour du fou prend
b3 et l'absolue car c'est pour ça qu'il
aurait pu laisser salir à 50
voilà donc il fait dessin raté cinq est
joué vous êtes des cinq échoué donc je
sais le coup que tu avais prédit
instantanément c'était le coup critique
n avoir rien de critique c'est vraiment
qui comprend cavaliers prend cavaliers
prend cavaliers prend tout en
choisissant une des variantes critiques
après syrien faut jouer autre chose
la commune h5 c'est tellement chaud ça
ça peut être chaud après t'es pas du
tout voir cette jeunesse avec les blancs
parce que mine de rien tu vois tu
après des 5 alors je pense qu'il faut
prendre des 5 es là tu peux réfléchir à
ce que tu fais parce que le plus inquiet
reste faible quoi que tu fasses donc
voilà je fais quoi tu fais c'est ce que
protégé b2 peut être une idée
ces trois vraies c'est le coût proposé
par l'andi mais sa piètre du sens ces
structures j'ai tellement mal les évalue
à chaque fois en fait le problème c'est
le ji aussi ouais c'est ça c'est 3 parce
que ok si tu dois jouer au fc schalke 4
après les toujours la question c'est
est-ce que tu peux continuer à donner le
pion sachant que l'option détroit s'est
affaibli en fins à l'aca est vraiment
des structures marshall qui se dessine
dans ces moments là et ça je sais parce
que je les avais travaillé notamment
pour le match
enfin pas cette position et ses
structures pour le match justement
carrière kim kirchen donc maintenue ce
qui l'est qui les connaît pas trop mal
ses positions ses positions mais pas que
si jean ah bah bien sûr hommes voilà les
deux connaissent les deux connaissent
donc voilà des cinq jouer j'imagine
qu'il a pris ou pas encore est encore là
encore on en riait réfléchi
il réfléchit à temps je peux te faire ce
temps je vais te faire un switch pour
que comme quand je partage l'écran qui
puisse voir puisse voir etienne aussi en
fait ce n'est pas tout le temps obligé
de bouger les pièces quoi ah oui tiens
c'est mieux pour toi j'imagine c'est
plus agréable non well as et bien non
elle vient va bien on bougera un peu
moins les pièces moi tu vois tu peux
nous donner ton ressenti aussi sur le
langage corporel de baky obala il est
content il a quarante minutes d'avancé
qu'ils respirent et clément une
meilleure préparation
enfin si tu pouvais espérer c'est
magnifique on me dira exactement quand
même et tu le laisses hautmont font sens
et tu vois ici des pâtes dans l'eau les
saumons avant d'atterrir dans le filet
de pêche baptiste anne est déjà réglé sa
petite bouteille d'eau il met le masque
magnus quand ils se déplacent terre
ouais c'est une obligation ou pas non
c'est un choix personnel
ce un choix perso damman vrai jusqu'au
match contre 15 à kinshasa m il masque
parce qu'il y avait eu des cas positifs
y avait pas mal de monde dans la salle
quand même le match nul car yakich
l'avais je l'attends enlevés cariat king
qui avait l'air qui a l'air d'être dette
revient en forme non avec des objectifs
j'ai pas qu'elle a ressenti vous avez
sur place mais oh bah déjà rien que les
prépas qui l'a placé la prépa dans la
bas-rhinoise oui c'est ça peut venir que
d'un mec là un minimum motivé ça c'est
sûr ça fait longtemps donc on voit plus
comme ça car yak web après au champion
de russie l'avait pas fini
deuxième un truc du genre le dernier
lire ici si loin derrière derrière dépôt
mais bon oui oui c'est sûr mais voilà
c'est pas le championnat du pakistan
ça reste ça reste un tournoi référence
non mais là ils avaient ils avaient
l'air mais même contre toi là à l'image
et tulare tout en hyper impliqués à 200%
a tout donné quoi enfin après il a
toujours été assez impliqués bon
évidemment comme il n'était pas qualifié
aux candidats tout ça c'est dur d'être
neutre en forme alors après je sais plus
ce qu'il avait fait en 2019
[Musique]
ils avaient dû jouer les grands prix
feed ah je sais plus j'ai l'impression
que non en fait si je pense il avait
joué à moscou en fait
ensuite il avait joué à un rig gaza je
me rappelle il avait perdu je prends un
armageddon au premier ou au deuxième
tour ok ouais possible et après on
l'avait durement dans le 3ème s'était
fait sortir rapidement si nous a pas
laissé un souvenir impérissable
voilà et mais la coupe du monde je sais
plus puisque la coupe du monde a
ressenti des jouets mattel plume après
ok il avait dû sortir sur un match très
chaud
comme d'hab en fait c'est de toute façon
ces matches là c'est rarement à à sens
unique c'est toujours de par son style
en fait il peut faire que des matchs
chauds parce qu'une brute et quand un
mec de ce calibre est sortie toute façon
c'est toujours des matches où j'ai eu
des matches et quantité de matches en
coupe du monde en fait invraisemblable
oui toi tu vas souvent jusque jusqu'au
rapide ou jusqu au blitz a way we et
puis je vais dire j'ai joué aussi tu
avais d'un gros calibre ça ça vaut quoi
ça peut les halles armageddon ça peut
aller 1 sur des rapides c'est toujours
avec vous avez aussi une
une puissance défensive qui est
impressionnante franchement quand tu
regardes les parties à vous défendez
ouais c'est des matchs donc tu vois la
défaite est interdite dans fait oui oui
s'allier à votre capacité de défense
systématique ces fameuses et us tous
très dur à battre
ça paraît tellement impossible c'est
comme ça que ça marche donc en tout cas
une équipe qui est assez impressionnant
brière notamment malheureusement mais du
coup les joueurs généralement n'ont
cessé plus sur la lof mène donc ils ont
pu faire l'impasse soit elle fait
l'impasse en verre sur lie la semaine
j'étais l'impasse sur l' île aux fans
mais là c'est différent parce que cette
fois ci le calendrier permettre le jouer
sans risque de devenir complètement
zinzin
la dernière fois c'était une semaine
après la fin de la coupe du monde
sachant sachant qu'ils avaient le match
pour la troisième place pour être bien
sûr que henry tour plus avec le match
pour la troisième place
pour être bien sûr que je n'y aille pas
laissez le moi j'avais l'impression vu
de l'extérieur que c'est le tout rend le
plus aléatoire de qualif aux candidats
la lof mais n'y a pas beaucoup devront
non c'était 7 9 et 11
ouais clairement après à la coupe du
monde aussi alors gros avantage parce
que au final c'est toujours des mecs
très forts qui vont qui vont au bout
alors même si même là j'ai envie de te
dire ce sera probablement des mecs très
fort qui est au bout et encore on va
dire que cette fois ci le tournoi était
un petit peu biaisé par le fait que par
exemple les vannes râlent les vannes
voilà les bonnes a été forfait etc
après c'est toujours des valeurs sûres
qui vont ils vont très loin en fait la
dernière vraie surprise de qualification
quand il a enfin vrai d'ailleurs je sais
pas si j'appelle cinq bras surprise
c'était andré keane en 2013
ouais en 2013 il était quand même à à
2010 ouais
monsieur 2013 dont c'était chronique en
break in ensuite en 2015 ces tests
fidler cardiaque in en 2017 c'était à
rognan dink et en 2019 c'était radjabov
ding wen ans donc ça de forêt étaient
des gros calibres
voilà après c'est vrai que par contre ce
format qui convient mieux à certains
joueurs qu'à d'autres donc bas notamment
à un mois d'écart jaeckin et cetera
allez bonne adding par exemple dans sa
base il doit être déçu de pas avoir pu
jouer tu sais si peu joué à line of six
joueurs iphone si les ans mais en fait
il y avait des joueurs chinois qui
jouait donc en théorie il aurait pu
jouer à la coupe du monde je sais pas
pourquoi il n'y est pas mais y'avait yu
yang et qui jouent à la wii dont il
aurait loué ignorant dire on l'a vu en
plus c'est partir il aurait pu venir
donc là c'est un mystère pour moi
pourquoi il a pas joué surtout qu'il
revenait un peu enfin voilà aimé tu as
des joueurs à qui donc le format coupe
du monde convient pas du tout alors le
premier exemple qui vient en tête c'est
caruana ans qui a fait au max un quart
de finale pour lui c'est dur ce camp
rapide il n'est pas encore trop rapide
les pas si mauvais mais à partir du 10
minutes il est pas fameux quoi ouais bah
oui mais ça reste bizarre du coup ça
reste une anomalie c'est le deuxième
joueur mondial de f1 indien sur l'ess
sur les trois quatre dernières années au
moins c'est le 3e c'est le deuxième
joueur mondial
après pourquoi est ce qu'il réussit pas
d'enfant raku parce qu'il est quand même
sens et en battre beaucoup en longues
voilà annoncé s'étonnant à aniche
également qui a notamment dans les
grands prix fitch fois qu'il a fait 1-0
compter sur deux tournois mais c'est 30
c'est étrange comme ça dit sud est
vraiment complet il est bon dans tout
les cadences ouais il ya un peu mon bon
en blitz est rapide et il a fait des
progrès récents on va dire mener mais
quand même
oui oui non il n'est pas à 100 c'est à
voilà donc
et du coup il a fait une demi finale lui
au max et je sais pas s'il a fait
d'autres cartes de finale ça me dit rien
en tout cas parce que là il s'est fait
éliminé haase et au final sans précédent
je dirais contre abdou cette prof
oui s'est fait éliminer contrat vous
prasat aux reflets ouais et s'était fait
éliminer également au troisième tour
entre réflexion que je crois en 2019
alors on ne sait pas des joueurs qui
sont censés être plus fort que lui loin
la voilà donc mais c'est bizarre que
voilà ce format conviennent si mal des
joueurs aussi complet et ce sera l est
les grands prix fit cette année c'est un
format un peu hybride c'est ça c'est un
format poule en premier puis après j'ai
rien compris j'ai rien compris j'ai rien
suivi des grands prix fille dont on
verra mon objectif c'est de ne pas les
jouer
ouais tu va déjà voir là il a fait nous
quoi mais je sais pas j'ai eu lui qui
fait un truc de fou pour moi j'aimais
bien dans l'idée c'est mais après on
n'était pas entré dans le détail quoi
c'est pas rentrer dans le détail et la i
lost my oms et ses 9 ou 11 rondes
juste avant 2 à 13 1 me dont ils ont
augmenté alors donc voix il a joué la
variante qu'on avait
contente toi et parler ils tiennent qui
aime bien jouer c'est rend donc il peut
pas il veut faire comprendre cinq ans
fait maintenant
ouais c'est ça l'âge prédit plus tour
des huit ans rapport qu'on y met la
pression et surprise prise prise surtout
que là là où manu sa confiance le plus
c'est dans ses capacités à jouer cette
position il se dit il va faire nul sans
problème dans cette position de foot des
six jeux ça peut ressembler comme tu le
disais à des gambie marshall avec toutes
les pièces du raquet sur le roi après le
pion d'être un peu faible faible après
après etienne qu'il est content 4
trente minutes avant ce tu penses que
s'il a une bonne position il gamberge
rats pour le terminer 11 ans et magnus
carlsen annaba qui où il est où il est
en totale confiance
seul moyen qu'à magnus de faire déjouer
afin de faire douter bâle qui s'est joué
des bons coups voilà si si je vous des
bons coups forcément ce sera ce sera
plus dur si ajouté pour par exemple que
baki n'a pas n'a pas tendance à orange
parce que parce que ça peut arriver mais
mais sinon s'il joue que des coûts si
même pas du fait qu'ils font pas douter
bâti beauty un qui part pour le défoncer
maintenant il a il a la bonne pause et
il avance autant voilà après
objectivement évidemment si manu se
trouvent tous les meilleurs coups bas
il sait qu'il va pas le battre c'est
normal ça c'est comme c'est comme contre
n'importe qui y voit la vie de dire j'ai
envie de dire c'est quand même important
du lantus en un tour à des mythes mais
magnus qui a pas l'air en grande
confiance à il prend quand même vraiment
son temps sur tous les coups un ouais
bah c'est pas une position agréable à
jouer déjà tu as tu mènes usam pas être
mis sous pression comme ça ils à mettre
en contrôle et il est il aime pas se
prendre des prépas dans la gueule il
sait évidemment que que le prêt a fait
ses devoirs évidemment donc voila et
puis bon bagage et une raisons notamment
pour laquelle l'actrice n'a pas joué par
exemple la berlinoise c'est parce
qu'évidemment et il n'a jamais aimé
jouer la berlinoise contre moi parce que
la finale sa salle emmerdes
ah et puis la finale en fussent etienne
etienne des jeux moins de réparations
c'est surtout qu'il la joue bien aussi
il a il a fait des dégâts aux victoires
de chine oui et puis en plus comme kobe
tu prépares que toi c'est ton c'est ton
répertoire mijn que lui les spécialistes
magnus dois bien dire que la berlinoise
il doit en avoir un fichier baky c'est
ça un messie fichiers sava facile facile
à réviser quelques lignes ligne entre
les bases ça suce asus a sué ça boit de
l'eau samedi à de l'eau de l'eau
norvégienne il a toujours ses bouteilles
à les bouteilles de son sponsor oui
c'est ça marrant ça ils vont être
emballé en lice et bouteilles avec lui
où il lui apporte
mais on voit des colis non mais leïla
toujours là c'est son père qui avait lui
donc c'est son parti doit gérer tous il
être amené les costumes les c'est le
concierge en fait il est toujours avec
lui à magnus face aux tourments il est
là où elles sont perella ger ger tout
l'extra sportif autour d'eux et je dis
que la france perd 4-0 contre le japon
ouais mais c'était c'était écrit
d'avancé donc ces jeux olympiques pour
l'équipe de foot ça se passe très mal à
écoute
ils étaient contents de se retrouver
ensemble
il aimait beaucoup les plus des équipes
qu'ils avaient à l'esprit dauphin qu'ils
avaient mis en place ils ont j'ai pas
suivi le deuxième match si on fait
contre l'afrique du sud a gagné 4,3 un
peu par miracle il y avait 3 2 pour
l'afrique du sud à dix minutes de la fin
ah ils ont mis à nu des deux buts pour
prendre l'aventage m'en vais là ils
soient éliminés c'est sa fin j'imagine
oui parce qu'ils ont fait 4 0 et 4 1 ils
doivent pas avoir de goal avérage
japonais de sushis d' grâce à ce genre
un peu le temps de suivre les jumeaux
maintenant ipod ce matin je me suis fait
un peu léger au c'ur match tv donc j'ai
pu et j'ai eu le grand plaisir de voir
un bat déjà les russes tu sais ils
peuvent pas concourir sous leur drapeau
elles sont très énervés j'imagine voilà
sans très énervé puis il y avait le
match un match de badminton alors il
jouait contre 1 à nos désirs le russe
autant dire que ça s'est mal passé
c'est pas la spécialité locale de
badminton et ils ont montré les sports
de raquettes en général bizarrement le
tennis c'est mieux depuis quelques temps
mais après celle et chez les femmes
s'étaient toujours pas mal et puis on
sera tirée safin le système tu t'es très
fort kafelnikov donc bon tennis y avait
toujours eu un peu mais bon badminton
j'imagine pas du tout donc là c'était là
la catastrophe et a pu voir le
contre-la-montre le contre-la-montre non
je vais rater enfin j'ai juste vu la
fusée prime aux bas qui fit j'ai gagné
ce contre la montre avait que quatre
minutes d'avancé sur rod lynch effet
après sur drogba qui ce matin annonce à
aller ça allait vite ce matin le contre
la montre
un hommage à neil plus vite que les
autres qui a vu tour à des 8 c'est le
coup que tu prédisait maxime oh et puis
c'est pas du tout à coup que je manipule
infos office on n'en parle pas parce que
quelques jets de fos est donc là il fait
quoi et ce qu'ils pensent pas qu'ils
prennent le pion il va peut-être jouer
un dame b3 ou un pion programme b3 et
pour ceux qui demandent dans cette lire
la russe était bannie et russie a été
banni par la wada c'est ça à cause des
histoires à sotchi non justement voilà
justement et vigeo et hiver où il y
avait eu des manipulations de
l'échantillon antidopage dans les
laboratoires etc
m c'est un truc de ouf fois la barre de
aufait dessus et du coup ils ont le
droit de concourir mais sous drapeau
olympique en gros pour faire simple
sympa sous le drapeau russe et ça c'est
valable également pour le championnat du
monde d'échecs donc assez ces matches on
est né poggi va devoir recourir sous
drapeau feed ah ouais c'est pas je
trouve on est pauvre cf
je suis déçu pour les peaux en fait je
le connais pas très bien je reviens tout
petit peu mais bon c'est forcément alors
si ça devait arriver à la france non à
la parade
on a le droit au pakistanais mais tu
seras un peu dedans si ça ça peut
arriver a probablement surtout qu'au
final tu paye les pots cassés pour un
truc absolument rien à voir quoi surtout
dans les échecs en fait j'en veux dire
il ya d'autres voilà c'est une chose
mais là tu es vrai frein et paula il a
vraiment aucun rapport quoi c'est pas de
chance c'est terrible et yasar dossche
qui arrivait dans le chat qui écrit à
laymont président aulas lequel il est ce
qu'à 1000 caleçon alors du coup on chip
est alors allé voir tes pas à les
vérifier
on a une très bonne relation avec betty
ann es tu vois ça ça s'arrête à l'examen
des caleçons n'était pas allaiter pas
aller chercher à vérifier
je suis pas allé vérifier mais y'a pas
de raison parce que non et paraiba tu as
forcément entendu le délire qui montent
sont fortes
d'emblée c'est sûr qu'il a c'est sûr
qu'ils ne savaient pas s'ils allaient le
mettre sur la table ou s'il avait sur
lui
alors ça c'est sûr qu'il l'a ouais ça
c'est sûr mais il a pris des gagneuses
échec aussi ou pas non il n'y avait pas
pris les affaires sont les affaires
pourtant il aurait pu en vendre un ou
deux à magnus après le match d'amélie là
il avait plein de livres à vendre à son
créateur
après leur match déjà tous les livres de
stratégie et tout
mais ponk rate of récémment quand on
analyse et la partie avec mathieu il
disait ponkrashov fils à jo en rapide
comme en blitz en fait d'ailleurs qu'il
a pensé que tu pouvais tout jouer tempo
et que tu as les magouilles et mais en
fait pas contrebas qui coiffe un web à
la salade de toute façon le lem le rap
il ça a toujours été la cadence la plus
difficile à maîtriser et de ce point de
vue là parce que tu peux pas jouer trop
vite ou trop lentement un juste milieu à
trouver moi j'ai souvent fait l'erreur
de jouer trop vite au début est tu dois
tu dois tu dois doser way utiliser ton
temps quand même parce que tu vas jouer
les bons coups mais tu dois regarder à
ses sous le coude pour terminer c'est
pas évident je ne vois là la question
c'est qu'est-ce que le presse va nous va
nous pondre ici ce que il a pas non plus
envie d'avoir une partie où ça rallonge
on va dire je pense bâti la contre
mcgill césar ils veulent agressé en tout
cas il veut pas le laisser à consolider
sa position puis ensuite placer ses
pièces voilà donc il prend 1,5 sas est
attendu après les tueries et maintenant
maintenant faut voir
bon là ça va être un vrai combat au
moins y'a pas de ya plus de
temporisation et davantage possible à
long terme de magnus en tout cas pas
pour le moment je crois qu'il a joués en
que notre coup mais que je mette un
refresh à la lewis ces quatre ans il a
fait la famille là je fous des six
l'autre coup c'est un peu dans le style
des positions qui ont regardé tout à
l'heure avec la tour qui peut partir en
fait oui il ya juste les changes
démission b5 en plus alors dans le
chaton 10 à parfaire la nulle alors bon
moi je vois le pion de plus je vois je
vois plein de pièces sur l'échiquier bon
oui ça parfois en une wii
comme toujours dans les échecs quand on
capable alors en fait
bon après est-ce qu'on pouvait avoir une
partie beaucoup plus animée que celle
qu'on a jusqu'à présent je suis pas sûr
vu le répertoire de chacun voilà donc
faut arrêter les faits que nous dans le
tchat
en fait ma news juste ce qu'il veut
c'est ça avoir une partie un peu
tranquille entre guillemets même si là
il n'y arrive pas complètement et
essayer de mettre la pression avec les
blancs demain et partir en rapide aux
caves ou quoi wayne on m'a presque il
aime bien avec les noirs aussi obtenir
une position entre guillemets jouable
voilà oui merci
le chat donc tu peux pas prendre en d5
avec la tour donc maintenue soit ce
qu'il veut c'est l opposition un peu de
joie où il a pas forcément l'avantagé en
tout cas où il peut justement commencent
à placer ses pièces et on va dire à
mieux jouer que l'adversaire en fait
donc voilà il va sur un must die
mais en tout cas c'est sa stratégie de
jeu à peu près tout le temps tu vois il
va pas chercher la nuit le forcer à
stériliser la position plus à ils et
c'est là que ici tiennent cois étaient
assez impressionnants sur les trois
jours faire quoi c'est assez assez
impressionnant il a beaucoup progressé
rios finale aller les russes sont
revenus en grosse forme quand même entre
n'est pas évidemment qui a passé un cap
car yakine qui remonte bien il ya six
benko voilà et les trois qui sont
soudainement tous les trois très bien
préparés aussi je pense qu'il ya des
moyens qui ont été mis à l'eau en tout
cas qu'ils ont des moyens humains je
sais pas exactement mais en tout cas
c'est assez impressionnant quoi voilà il
faut il faut redorer le blason de la
russie c'était assez descente directe de
poutine a dû poutine derrière forcément
voilà paver les rues de toute façon
c'était une anomalie qu'il la petite
période là ya eu un passage à vide
c'était plus possible quoi précariat
keane et 3 4 ans difficile c'est ça
ouais même si gris tchouk un peu ouais
ben whishaw qu'en fait les normes
joueurs je les aime beaucoup
par contre il a gagné heureusement trois
championnats du monde de blitz oui mais
c'est absolument tout en fait
il a jamais vraiment menacé de gagner
les candidats à ce quoi que il a menacé
mais il ya très longtemps c'était la
coupe du monde j'ai perdu contre galles
fendent ouais c'est ça c'était en 2011
ça c'était un match à élimination
directe
mais sinon il n'a jamais gagné un
tournoi
tiens donc si il a gagné les trois
champions du monde oublie ce qui est
énorme dans un palmarès au final mais
mais c'est tout alors que toi tu t'es
pas s'il est gagné un tournoi genre
envahie qu'elle faisait alors n'en reste
peut-être qu'il a gagné 1 linares vega
très longtemps si au final ça fait 15
ans qu'il est dans l'élite après les
réguliers a great choc
ouais bah évidemment il a même et il est
même fait une pente à 28,20 donc oui la
foule a retenu mais en fait ce qui lui a
coûté je pense aussi beaucoup en partie
longue c'est qu'au final il est trop
souvent avec note
ah bah oui ça c'est difficile à croire
non et puis il a quand même gagné un
grand prix fidh quand même celui d'un go
oui voilà on m'a après les grands
profits devraient pour moi c'est
différent pour moi je vois plutôt ça tue
c'est camille s'est qualifié aux
candidats via les grands prix fidh ouais
oui bah oui oui ça reste quand même
temps c'est un palmarès voilà ai donc
dit linares aussi voilà mais c'est vrai
que pour un joueur aussi énorme
au final sa fiche de palmarès
c'est bien je crois tu vois oui oui même
je le considère foncièrement plus fort
que que car yakine oui mais non papa
cakin un palmarès bien plus étoffé quoi
voilà déjà gagné les candidats sait déjà
quoi il a gagné les candidats il a gagné
la coupe du monde
il a gagné également champion du monde
de bli de saint charles a dû vous rapide
en fait j'aimerais ça c'est énorme car
il ya qui n'a pas donc avec qui ne
s'éteint le palmarès qu'il a il a failli
gagner le match du championnat du monde
en plus de ça ouais non mais il ya un
palmarés stien palmarès meilleur que
karen elkin actuellement la carte scène
caruana quand même à landing non à
rognan à rognan même si à rognan il
avait gagné beaucoup de tournois et donc
on va dire à rognan
même s'ils n'ont bien sûr que non bah
vichy 1 mais bon quel vie oui bon dj le
succès reste un vivier pour vichy
beaucoup trop fort champion du monde ces
voix là voilà quand même autre chose
mais encore impressionnant encore un
cantat quand tu la joues et la zagreb
c'est fou encore le niveau qu'ils
développent oui ça tu a impressionné
tout à l'heure tu t'y attendais avoir
vicieux aussi fort e
non non non parce que ça faisait 16 mois
qu'il n'avait pas joué donc j'ai été
très impressionné franchement ça j'ai
trouvé je les attendais pas du tout
banon mais surtout la partie qui m'a le
plus impressionné c'est celle entre mois
là le premier pli de la laddh derniers
mois ah oui allez ne pas les dingues
celle là ouais c'est c'est du jamais vu
pour il m'a trouvé dix seul coup de
suite je me rappelle être regardé en
direct est utilisé par nanan de là quand
il joue à ce niveau là c'est tu peux
faire quoi en fait tu as l'impression
que que c'est le papy qui vient et qui
titre mais à la place c'est le vieux
d'aaron qui viserait en fait très fort
mais
mais il ya vu chi chi chi encore
au-dessus qua non il était vraiment fou
dans cette partie oui complètement
il était aussi impressionnant que
kasparov mais pas pour les mêmes raisons
je m'en fiche
on était obligé on a été obligé troll
kasparov on pouvait pas faire autrement
oui mais après et il va retenter sa
chance
le cahier qu'un aliev catch ou encore
magnus l'ordi aime pas trop mais presque
logique hein après c'est pas le seul
coup au genre il ya un truc classique
c'est de jouer genre tour f-18 et faux
en fuite
mais c'est un peu long mais bon cavalier
f4 j'ai envie de te dire tu joues pour
prendre la terre de foot attaque le pion
des trolls plongée 2 du force presque
laprise j'imagine mais prise prise là il
faut voir un match 5
la deuxième ligne comme toi et de leurs
barrages 5 mai prochain tweet j'aime
bien ce que l'on dit il
pour les noirs malheureusement menace
battait pour fonder 3 et surtout si tu
joues jordan match 3 parce que tout
reprendre d'être au taf ou bien mais là
tu vas jouer autour des 6 par exemple
exactement mais en tout cas le risque
pas avec les blancs non plus bon là
peut-être n'ont jamais de base
si tu fais fi non la scpa non tu peux
jouer quatre matches mais c'est très
pleutre des 4
les cartes se calme baky il est bâti il
est plus très clair et il jouera pas des
4 des cas c'est quoi ces prises prise
prise à la fête des 4 le problème c'est
la semaine du c4 au final tu le sais tu
vois genre c'est qu'à touba f5
tu peux te faire vie c'est comme ça avec
le pion de qui avance jamais été vice à
dos ouais ouais il faut bien en fait
c'est surtout la question la
problématique du foot bien ça c'est des
positions qui soufflent un peu les yeux
fermés c'est à dire même si même si tu
connais pas trop les positions
comme moi tu joues ça les yeux fermés
est-ce facile à jouer vrai c'est facile
à jouer donc non je pense que wayne
prise prise keyyo casbah prison elles
quatre ces forces et sa salle avantage
c'est complètement forcé crise est là le
cheval de capital classique c4 c'est
forcément parce que quelquefois je
relâche un holà attentes autant c'est
quoi cette ligne roche
si des forces et de faire sa ba match 3
qui est tombée cette dame h4 l'insee
parce qu'il prend des huit fois c'est
fou comme hymne d'un match 5 matches et
je les sens du f3 tour du 8c trouvable
mais bon faut du présent le damage trois
dames h4 franck cavallier e46 je vous
passe et 4 auquel il ad'autres cook c4
mais ça après qu'elliot 4 est bien
implanté pour l'instant et surtout tapas
de f5 parce que dalphond à 2 j'ai su à
âmes c6 du coup ils protègent le pays
menace matt damon à se battre si tu
bouges lecavalier quoi ouais mais tu te
voilà pour le moment tu peux pas
l'attaqué le cavalier seul avantage ça
ça peut ça peut être ça peut être le
coup de bas qui fait voir la cam ce qui
donne maquiller gratte la tête
je pense que bon il sait qu'il va
prendre un f4 mais il réfléchit
mais après la guerre deux écoles soit tu
joues le coup et tu veux tu joues ou
forcés et tu réfléchis avec la
cotisation sous les yeux voilà moi c'est
ce que je ferai ici parce que tu as un
coup vraiment forcé après parfois d'un
cookie et force
c'est entre guillemets meta on va dire
un autre coup qui est potentiellement
jouable est donc là tu laisses même si
tu sais que tu vas jouer ce coup tu
décides de faire comme laisser
l'adversaire dans le berger en se disant
que tu peux jouer l'autre coup oui oui
c'est normal
voilà mais là comme ses forces et je
pense que je prendrai en f4 et ensuite
après il peut aussi tenter ou encore
mieux j'attends que le bel adversaire se
lève lève c'est ce que j'allais venir la
marne ou tri n'est jamais finie on peut
attendre qu'ils se lèvent et puis un
petit fou prend 4 ambulants et tu gagnes
une minute un ouais à semmar luz a ouai
mais il a pas l'air de se lever la
glisse ça ça peut être très très marleau
il peut le faire baky ça ça c'est dense
orange à ses dents sont daniel avoir
c'est tendu comme partie en tout cas
etienne qui fait ce qu'on attendait de
lui un une grosse game au bon on attend
d'être pas moi j'ai juste un petit coup
d'oeil par curiosité aux autres sans se
plonger quoi juste pour savoir savoir la
chante la voilà chante là toi aussi dû
coûter supporters de l'as chang la pâte
l'air en vrai alors je sais plus comment
ça marche ça m'arrange dans toi ça
t'arrange ce soir que ce soit car yakine
qu'ils y aillent aux candidats non mais
si ces lâches en classe at arrangements
à métaux rares grands prix reine en toi
tu es poussière yacine web et après et
moi j'ai la chance là aux candidats
c'est beau quand même la championne oui
après ça dépend je me qualifie aux
candidats est ce que j'ai envie de voir
carrier qui nous est ce que j'ai envie
de voir la chante là pas plus en
relâchant que là je prends voilà
maintenant plus il a l'air sympa à la
came sepa et mathieu m'a dit qu'il était
très bizarre
montréal j'avais vu déjà y parle
français il parle vraiment français ou
pas parce que mathieu m'a dicté par les
foules onglets à l'analyse il parle
assez
bien français déjà un point positif
voilà et ses bouquins sont vendus sur
alpha échec
on voyait le presse qui prend un petit
pourcentage à chaque fois donc à la wii
koné pour la chante la voilà clairement
à mon avis à mon avis pas qui est en
train déjà de signer des contrats pour
les prochains et l'acheter en claquer un
petit avantage alors après cdac
désavantage temporaire en fait c'est que
là il faut trouver un coup de boutoir
s'y trouvent encore c'est la position
peut s'écrouler mais sinon ça va
égaliser de tranquillement on va voir
tabataba et je sais pas si tu as tu as
forcément entendu dans live on n'a pas
le bon iranien c'était ça va ça va resté
ce truc mais le problème c'est que avec
la ffl en fait si on avait chopé le bon
iranien se serait de facto devenu le
mauvais c'était si c'est passé
d'ailleurs oui oui ça a été le voit
venir à néant laver et puis en fait on
l'a on là pour la logique c'est ont la
poisse et mai mais joue pas mal en plus
le tabac tabassé un bon jour je pensais
pas qu'il était aussi jeunes d'ailleurs
mais il est là quoi 21 22 ans
feydeau seief moi j'étais étonné de le
voir à ce niveau il a très bien joué il
a été un rouleau compresseur
jusque là est ce que tu t'es les russes
ils ont ils ont dû bosser ensemble il
doit y avoir un truc c'est pas possible
en fait ils ont tous l'air d'avoir
progressé quoi réellement
ouais faut que je retourne à moscou
parce que je peux savoir d'où ça vient
en fait une pièce dans la fédération
russe des échecs avec une salle
climatisée avec une méga turbine avec
une mega mega mega turbines mais ça
c'est quand j'y suis allé il ya trois
ans mais peut-être que depuis a eu un
bébé mais quand je voyais quand j'ai eu
mes gars turbine sais je sais pas la
pièce elle doit faire elle est plus
grande que - al wafeer minimum 30 mètres
carrés la pièce et à un serveur
enfin les ventiler climatisé machin est
le truc à l'intérieur quand je suis allé
visiter
non mais c'est énorme en fait c'est
c'est pas une turbine toi c'est
l'équivalent de 200 turbines collées les
unes aux autres quoi
j'imagine bien que je sais pas combien
ça peut coûter mais ça m'a l'air d'être
du matériel ccir en dehors des moyens de
bec qui se tenait pour l'instant ouais
je pense que si j'ai un truc à un
chiffre au hasard un métier au hasard
visu c'est plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros quoi c'est sûr vu ce
que tu décris c'est sûr
non c'est énorme c'est énorme et donc tu
as une pièce où est vraiment à une pièce
dans la fédé russe avec avec ce truc là
quoi une pièce dédiée où il fait bon
aller l'été parce qu il fait moins chaud
quoi c'est ventilés de ouf ça s'adapte
ainsi aux couleurs ou obligés de
travailler mais bon tu vois s'il avait
ça et que ils ont paru d'une manière x
ou y trouver autre chose ça peut aider à
mon avis pas trop bas ça c'est sûr et je
sais que tous les joueurs russes de haut
niveau ils y ont accès en fait tu peux
pas c'est pas privatisée en fait tu vois
c'est pas genre tiens tu es né peau tu
es le numéro un il ya que toi qui as
accès en fait ça marche pas comme ça
oui heureusement heureusement réussi et
de toute façon si on abaisse sa
disposition en france ce serait
évidemment ça comme ça que ça marcherait
aussi on sape allez je serai pas etienne
et moi qui avons axé mon envie de rogers
non tout le monde
tout le monde y aura accès alors
évidemment après la fédé la fédé n'a pas
les mêmes moyens que la fédération ici
aussi c'est aussi comme ça la russie
c'est quand même un pays historiquement
d'échec un donc après on est là on est
pas mal équipés mais c'est sûr que oui
non mais c'est tu peux pas être à un
niveau individuel c'est à pas par magnus
et peut-être caruana qui peut être
équipé comme ça aujourd'hui personne
c'est ça c'est pas déjà il faut il faut
l'espace déjà rien que ça il faut lire
l'informaticien maya l'informaticien de
la fédé c'est un pote en fait qu'il
veuille bas c'est lui qui gère le truc
face et c'est pas un truc que tu peux
brancher et puis c'est fini ça tourne
aravane a bah oui mais ça je sais que
j'étais en discussion à une époque
justement et c'est un bordel monstre
parce que en fait les logiciels d'échec
aussi sans mal au moins l'époque était
mal joué c'était très difficile de les
faire tourner sur sur les meilleurs sur
les meilleurs systèmes d'exploitation et
c'est donc à la wii n'est pas une
nourrice l'iranien par ailleurs il est
pas la position des blancs les coûts là
on en est on a va normaux mais moi
jamais en quoi tu va envoyer à 5 b 5
points devant voit alors après faut
qu'ça faut que ça marche mais mais ouais
je trouvais pas trop de coups pour pour
fait dos et du coup il nous reste le
joueur du gange
le jour 1 du camp je tire un petit peu
mieux mais rien de spécial
on doute acquis fait assez forte
impression quand même tu vois même pour
le coup lui c'est un joueur à qui ce
format convient pas trop mal qui est
plutôt bon rap il dévoila et suite des
bons résultats
10 incroyable bas qu'il a trouvé la
première ligne de leur dit non à temps
c'est pas ça a toujours le même bug il a
joué fouquereau f4 bref quatre
incroyable performance de fady qui
trouve le seul coup voilà et business
il a fini par le jouets mais il a pas
encore ouais voilà donc du coup il a
affiné par peut-être que manu c'est
resté trop longtemps devant l'échiquier
du coup il n'a pas tenu et il a fini par
craquer
c'est gris tout dans une interview il
disait que jouer contre tout dasté que
jouer comme comme contre free de ce 3 à
il ya un peu de vrai c'est tout les
quizz et ses joues il joue comme un ordi
mais pas trop trop forte
ouais y'a un peu moins
après peut-être maintenant même fric
5,32 le fameux fritz ans
32 je connais pas frites 5,32 sénardes
la légende habitations que je connais
pas ouais en fait je sais plus en 2001
alors je sais plus pourquoi ça
s'appelait les frites 5,32 si c'était
parce que tu es 32 étaient trop payés
non c'était soit une frite s'inquiétait
trop bédié soit le fric si c'était peu
après la sortie mais j'étais un peu
jeune donc je me rappelle plus et du
coup tu jouer a analysé avec frites 5,32
à cette époque-là déjà ou pas est une
autre époque
ils disent que stockfisch 13 propose
damage cinq mois je jouerai plus toqué
le 4 mai c'est le coup plus pratique
après après le prêt silva il va se
présenter
on va voir ça on va voir ça t'inquiète
pas il écrit pour le son il ya un
problème pendant trois secondes mais
c'est c'est servenu normalement je crois
que c'est un c'est un seul c'est un
problème software qui règle son plus bas
ne t'inquiète pas non plus à être aussi
j'ai dénoncé pour connaître c'est un
truc software cd x windows il décide on
sait pas pourquoi de baisser mais je
remontais surtout ne pas entendre le
ministre
alors il joue cavalier au cat écoute
c'est le coût que nous on avait plutôt
enfin que toi tu avais plutôt privilégié
et donc la ligne c'était quoi c'était c4
et c5 fourrage de avec le damage 3 et
tous étaient complexes et doit déjà faut
trouver un an après il ya un autre coup
ces dames c'est cette évidence et le
presse qui se lèvent le presse qui se
lève et dames c'est cette lamanon
peut-être il va faire beau match 5 alors
lui aux républicains qui donne puces
défectueuses je vais devoir vérifier ça
mais je crois que c'est une fête news
maquis qui passe de 1706 gagne ça
m'étonnerait dans attend il a gagné
aurait gagné des points ou parce que en
top12 il y en a pas vraiment gagner non
hu alors là c'est une fille news
invraisemblable c'est honteux non le
presque yaa diem passé les 2700 déjà
mais sur le classement rapide
en fait oui sur le rapide ça fait un
moment qu'il au-dessus dès 2009
dès 2007 pardon et même des bouddhas
vivants l'offrir suivant le classement
voilà donc non il est de 1700 à
l'échelle pakistanaise peut-être pas la
première fois que la république un
mouvement n'est pas mal la blague du
chat quand même on est obligé de elle
était belle à les valider elle est
validée donc le carélien quattro est ce
qu'un jour il ya du cavalier f6 qui peut
tomber on ne sait pas non ça va pas
tomber si tu n'as pas de dalle g4 en
fait sinon lequel six pouvait-on jan van
damme g4 bon là son prochain coup si peu
ses cahiers français 5 et suivant ce qui
peut se passer c'est à mach 5 ça protège
la h-2a a taxé 5 et ça tape ça tapait
vii aussi ça peut servir non basse et 4
la 32e minute 1 pour magnus why are baky
qui vient un peu voir ce qui se passe
bien prendre sa bouteille d'eau offre
twikin qu'il achevait fake news aussi
est-ce que je vote à droite moi seul le
sait déjà j'ai peu goûté les dernières
élections
moi j'ai voté baki ouais
oui c'est complètement obligatoires ben
moi j'aurais voté bâti mais j'avais deux
grandes questions at a pas pu voilà tu
étais tu t'es libérer de son obligation
citoyenne je double vote
c'est ça les prochaines élections je
vois pas qui alors après ce que vos
débats qui s'est voté à droite je t'aime
c'est probable côté papilles à mon avis
ça fait très mal choisi moi je vote
qu'accros bâti qui envoient des squats
taiba qui s'est beaucoup il a pris sa
bouteille aurait bâti qu'il va gagner
les élections présidentielles 2022
serait magnifique qui se présente quand
même
il va chercher les chassant signature
sans se présenter à 100 soit lancée
juste les gens qui eux qui veulent
acquis d'europe ce serait extraordinaire
chaque affaire bah oui moi je le fais
moi je fais après t'as pas le droit de
photos de tomber aucun devenu grand non
c'est interdit c'est absolument interdit
je sais pas tu n'as pas le droit
bon alors il est parti et du coup magnus
il reste salée ce qu ils nous mettent
pas de façon il ne met pas magnus sur
l'autre camsa réfléchis tu pense qu'il
peut trouver le c4 et le damage croit
ces danses orange ou pas assez dur dur
dur
je pense qu'il va jouer c'était quoi le
ku'damm c5 c6 ouais ouais je pense que
les dogues 6 vraiment tu vois je pense
que mais alors après attention parce que
d'un côté il a pas envie de s'embêter à
calculer des vins trop trop difficile de
l'autre un moment faut bien calculer
qu'en fait face à un baquet de combat et
requins tabac les les déchets verts il
est déchaîné il est déchaîné adams et si
ce truc c'est qu'après si bas qu'il a le
temps de faire barrage cinq tours d un
il a un vrai pion de plus à un moment
donné ça peut faire mal ou dame g4 je
sais pas moi d'amc pas est-ce que s'il
réussit à bien consolider sa position le
pion plus on peut le lavoir propre
danser dans ses positions
lancer réussit à mettre sa tour en d1 et
faire un des quatre où la paire de fois
elle sera toujours pénible c'est ça à la
paire de fois va toujours être pénible
en fait mais par contre fait la question
c'est est-ce que tu réussi à garder le
client leucan si tu réussis c'est bien
si à un moment tu te prends moi je suis
tel 5 ça c'est le seul cas en fait tout
ça peut dégénérer
parce que les fourons trop taper si t'as
plus le cavale ça c'est ça voilà je vais
donc là dans le c6 ouais ouais ça semble
être un coup logique il va pas trop
traîner à mon avis magnus non plus pour
ce couple ce qui lui reste 18 coups
derrière
ou alors il est en train de calculer ces
quelques essais cinq français le
trouvera mine de rien mais voilà ça
demandait un gros effort et puis faut
pas se tromper dans les calculs non plus
ses troupes à un tronc par l'endroit tu
peux perdre aurait pu il aurait pu en
jouer ses 4o coups un groupe où c'est
celui-là
enfin c'est celui-là c'est celui-là je
crois je croyais qu'il veut mais c'est
peut-être lui quatre avants avant à pied
prendre cinq des six tours un haut lieu
de carrière car si et le foot de six
très bien c'était ici c'était la tête un
coup franc t'imagines l'alourdît qui
nous donne les précisions 99,4 pour si
j'avais fait ces 4 pour les blancs 99,6
pour les noirs ces genres partie
parfaite des deux côtés en fait ouais
c'est quasiment foule partie parfaite de
toutes façons à votre niveau
selon les caps
après quand on n'utilise pas lesquelles
ces différents non plus les caps si son
bail va je voudrais pour des parties
rapides
il a joué au lycée il a il a levé sa
main au dessus d'une pièce de toute
façon c'est soit le pion c'est soit la
dame
il n'ya pas à ce qu'ils pouvaient dames
c'est cette non à il est jeune dame c7
bon je confirme
du coup ils menacent
présage de c'est un coup forcément je
pensais faire à damas 5 oui on n'a pas
non on n'a pas notre dame ce set mais
c'est un coup bien sûr au même titre que
dams et 607 cette dame h5 ski la tour
prends des trois noms sur laquelle
insiste simplement des fois je dois je
pensais âmes c5 haye assurant foubert à
la fin ray mond un troll parce qu'il
prend 6,5 perdait 1 à cause de jets six
gîtes rome
mais du coup être prend des trois
lentilles mais j 3 c'est un coup facile
c'est hyper si fort c'est fort c'est
hyper fort tuera les fours b1 sur
lesquels français 5 tu vas tout avoir en
fait ouais non ça du coup tu peux pas
prendre en d3 et du coup tu dois jouer
c4 et là oh quel avantage
maintenant c'est que t'as plus à
calculer sky is et 5
ouais parce que tu allais tour des cinq
voulait g6 voilà donc en vrai le
pressent qu'il va devoir être fin prêt
sinon parce que tu as des as des coûts
en as tu peux jouer j'ai trois déjà ici
mais tu tu affaiblis tout à fait milan
la grande diagonale
tu tu as fait bien à long terme après
est-ce que c'est très grave
mais bon ça va demander trois coups
quand même au noir pour pour utiliser sa
rage suite à cinq et dames c6 way et
puis il faut 7 tu te placer un petit
fawcett au 6 mai mais bon ça peut vite
devenir désagréable aussi donc ouais bah
qui est pas encore revenu à bas il n'est
pas encore revenu
étendant mais s'est dit c'est normal
parce que là je
mais l'oeil par la fenêtre il vient de
sortir de la piscine encore tirer parti
parti se baigner
voilà sacre en train de signer des et
chic
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
est ce que va qui devrait faire un pitch
trim impôts le stream ce serait beau
ouais ouais ça serait magnifique
je pense à pour être mythique et oui
voilà arrimer un jacuzzi devant sa cape
chez lui et voilà c'est parti
à combien de seube est ce que est ce que
tu vas qui sort le top stream
je pense dix mille sabots ça vaut
beaucoup au top ce remake baczyk j'ai
adoré le délire aussi quand alors c'est
avant-hier quand il est si benko était
parce que j'ai fini en cinq minutes
ayissi peine coûts et les primes beaux
gosses et puis derrière la gamme sur
baky de presse alors vos gosses ou pas
des récipients nico aubin évidemment
parce que parfois en vrai c'est pas
pareil que la cam
bah oui c'est la future égérie que les
échecs
il se présente bien plus beaux gosses
que les peaux ça c'est sûr
à mon avis ce n'était pas très difficile
pas trop ça troll cette rolls donc et le
presque est toujours pas revenu le
prestige en a plus rien à [ __ ] le
presse qui va cliquer au hasard c'est
beau que le prez qui se présente contre
bagneux si ce bar aba un magnifique rose
les bras qui tire c'est dur de jouer
donc le pakistan femmes et maylis henry
s'attendait pas à voir un bac est aussi
puissant aujourd'hui à leur tour de
papier qui a retroussé les chemises ans
tra qu'il a repoussé les chemises montre
de beaucoup trop de respect je trouve le
saumon alors ils nous envoient d'un
match 5 tu penses où j'ai trois types à
regret sur kelkoo j'espère d'un match 5
donc on va parler d'un match 5 à les
dames c'est ça tu penses qu'il avait
calculé ou pas c'était dans dans les
coups qu'il a envisagé après cavaliers
ou 4 au 8 septembre sont daniel je pense
dams et 7 c'est un chromo j ouer excusé
faille qu'il est en train de faire un
puzzle rush c'est pas possible
oh non il est pas en train de faire un
puzzle rech il fait un peu d études lui
pendant les tournois ou pas abba qui va
gâcher bois non bah là et ici sur ce
tournoi là en fait t'as pas tu fais pas
en fait tu fais pas autre chose quoi tu
te prépares autre chose c'est faux c'est
sans moi
ouais ce qui est toujours là à dire j'en
vois des trucs à maxime les temps voit à
bah oui mais pas pas ici avant les
tournois t'envoie un peu tout huit
gardes des des études et où les feuilles
well as je l'appelle j'étais en train de
faire qu évidemment je suis en train de
trouver des études pour maxime je paye
est tout le temps sur le coup quoi
bah oui oui c'est qu il sait que c'est
pas moi qui vais bosser par moi même
donc il envoie à fond voilà et c'est
magnus qui par là et puis en plus c'est
pas facile de trouver des des exercices
en fait si québec banq d'exercice
vraiment alors qu'elle pour les joueurs
de mon niveau ce serait facile
évidemment je les ferai ces exercices là
mais tabac en fait est obligé d'avoir
quelqu'un qui te trouve cette position
parce que moi aussi je trouve des
positions super je vais me trouver des
positions très difficile à résoudre mais
je vais aussi avoir les solutions web
aouine on ne peut pas le faire toi même
ça voilà ça c'est vraiment un beau jeu
annonce est obligé d'avoir quelqu'un qui
les trouvaient ça doit pas être facile
non
trouver des positions pour toi nan bas
surtout que en plus bâties mais la barre
assez haut derrière donc je peux vite
les trolls et cette position
elles sont souvent tirés de partie où il
s'est créé les positions il fait quoi
hausse est tirée de quartier ou tirer si
non tirée de position qu'on analyse en
faites de position d'ouverture
ça aussi c'est important bondam c7
etienne qui se concentrent c'est un coût
important là dans la partie 1 celui-là
c'est un coût important ouais ouais j'ai
trois possibles dommages 5e possible un
brin magnus qui a trouvé une bonne série
de coups du coup là bas il a vraiment
bien je trouve
hyundai on a un gros un gros tournoi un
gros mâle gros match ouais à ses
dépositions de maîtrise assez bien quand
même deux mineurs général c'est pas pour
rien qu'il est champion du monde
au revoir mais il n'est pas encore
champion du pakistan il essaye
aujourd'hui à dire d'obtenir le droit de
jouer le tournoi en fait
en fait ça ce match c'est peut-être
qualificative pour le championnat du
pakistan elle va alors demi finales des
candidatures en battant le prez au
passage c'est ça la question c'est
est-ce que carrier qui n'a gagné le
droit de disputer mon avis oui imagine
j'imagine seebach auckland
assima champ droit il a joué cette dame
c'est 7 et baky qui bloque un peu on
refait un petit tour des stades
allez un mini tour des stades pour
savoir un peu si chaque land justement
comment en parler maintenant sa tenue
ans
steria qui ne sert d'être solide ici un
fou rue en plus attention quand même
il peut y avoir un risque de laisser un
peu de la sciure bien ses caisses et 4g
6 e 4 maintenant tu prends des jeunes
pions je prends déjà le pion en fait là
je pense à québécismes et déjà prendre
le pion et kébé 6 au prochain coup on
était quand même bien stoppés mais ça
peut s'il ya quelqu'un qui lie c'est les
noirs dont ici voilà c'est ça oui pas
forcément nettement moins bien mais on
me tue faire et ce que je joue bien
cookies ces cas jesse parce que la
turbine est non non non c'est ça reste
sale alignerait je pense c'est le 4 h 4
nages 4 c'est bizarre quand même
déjà il ya kébé si ce qui m'inquiète tu
vas commencer à te faire après ça peut
aussi entre guillemets bien tourner mais
ça peut très mal tourner qu'est donc ça
serait bien tourné et si tu arrives à
installer ton cahier tirage 4 ans et 4
c'est une fois que tu arrives à présent
la position à revenir mais c'est long
ouais ok donc le championnat assez fait
aulas c'est chaud ou 4,4 jouer et c'est
brouillon mais je prendrai toujours les
blancs - pratique après après 4000 da
sera le sait c'est le seul truc à g iii
joué par bâti on revient où on fait un
mini à leurs familles
visite du zoo où il se passe by sapphire
nul donc baky qui a joué g3 et donc qui
attaquent le fou et magnus et magnus qui
va devoir reculer le fou là blement des
six voies là et bien là il va falloir
être prêt pour la suite de la partie ce
qui peut se faire contrer sur cases
blanches il peut se faire contrer sur
cases blanches etienne après tout des
six peut-être le truc c'est que j'ai
jamais envie de jouer des quatre parce
que tu vas en fait j'aurais envie si tu
vois si les nord prenne et que tu fuck
you me rends et qu'ensuite tu joues tu
des 5 mai des quatre j'ai peur des c4 du
coup tu peux te faire complètement vis
et après à blanc par le fou après t'as
pas jamais le temps de farfouiller un
genre bouger le cavalier c'est de faire
flouer 4 way là je voulais justement la
caf ce à quoi on avait déjà parlé
oui et avec le pire angers de france et
ça peut dégénérer
alors à temps il a joué et on diffuse
cinq jeux met un petit refresh g3 fouet
voilà c'est possible aussi là oui oui
non bien sûr
en fait j'ai utilisé des 6es qu'en vrai
qu'en turmel font de cette technique
tant avec les mares le fond le 7 c'est
comme si tu avais de la fourrure 5 tu as
peut être besoin de re des places est
aussi un jour voyez pas j'ai par exemple
sur dame de qu'est ce que tu fais ce que
tu menaces qu'il pensait 5 way fait le
fou est simplissime pas stable alors
après ça va de foot des six est
paradoxal tutelle la perte de fou mais
sauf que tu peux pas vraiment la prendre
fait c'est pour ça que ça semble à 6,6
envisageable la fosse 5 ça paraît pas si
mauvais hein oui non bien sûr
ce que j'aime bien par exemple ici ce
serait toujours quelque chose comme 4
trop quand même
s4 f5 ça peut ça peut ça peut donner
envie dans le sens où tu peux te suisse
ouais et le 4 mai bon c'est pas vraiment
ce futur moi ce que je voulais faire là
c'est tout re trois dames le 2 comme ça
à tout moment ton cavaliers les plus
récentes à la case f3 qui est protégé
vrai voilà même si t'as pas spécialement
vide de mettre son cavalier sur le sur
le toit jambon après la magnus il obtenu
ce qu'ils voulaient et obtenu la
position qui peut tourner à trois
résultats
ouais c'est ça mais bon le président a
du temps attention pour les prochains
goukoye j'ai envie de dire les prochains
sont importants ça peut tourner d'un
côté ou de l'autre cette partie en tout
cas le prestige je le vois plus à la
piscine depuis quelques minutes est là
ça va jouer il va jouer dans quand il
commence à y va jouer quand il commence
à faire un petit geste vers le visage et
que ça va partir mais magnus il a pas
l'air d'être très bien encore
physiquement là dans le langage corporel
n'a pas l'air d'être en méga confiance à
laymont baky un bâti qui veulent jouer à
l'est qui va jouer tous les trois ça
c'est un coup pour mon bac y aller
cliquer au hasard bas qui au pire à
habas un moment va falloir cliquer
voisins de l'est faut pas qu'il oublie
la grande technique bac east and s du
clic au hasard hein
ce qui fait le secret de ses joueurs
c'est ça ça avait déjà bien fait les
affaires de baky contre ravis ils
avaient cliqué au hasard il nous avait
dit ça en après match or tellement qu'il
faut cliquer au hasard j'ai passé piqué
au hasard moyens
si j'avais six avec les kids au hasard
ça ce serait peut-être mieux passer la
partie retour ya aucun monde où
normalement ça doit tenir ce qu'il a
fait mais bon non mais ouais c'était
près d'am dessin que j'ai passé trois
minutes a calculé qu'il prince estime
marchait pas d'âme la suite je croyais
que ça marchait pas trop mais en fait
c'est ça le jour a dû faire f4 jouer au
la f4 jouer eux quatre rouges n'ont pas
arrêté qui sont matrix et par les ordis
ouais donc tu vas jouer quoi je me fous
des six ses forces et forcé est là bas
qui veut quoi il vint coûte damman deux
rives foccart place 900 en fait ouais
peut-être tam g4 à ces quatre déjà un
nas f5 et si tu commences par f5
séquelles des 4 à 8
oui ça c'est toujours à oui ça c'est
chiant ça ça c'est très chiant est le
fruit bouge plus après demain ça tu peux
pas ea mais c'est pour ça que ça peut
devenir désagréable c'est l'idée tour à
87 et du coup tu veux pas parce que fout
bien tu laisses se situait 5 abattant
stabiliser à la tête des trois dames
prend ses shoots mais bon en vrai ça
c'est un combat de rue oui tout peut
arriver
il a fait foot et si je crois si ça peut
être un point inquiétant la bourbaki
quand même s'il n'a pas le temps de
stade stabilisé
dommage je pense que c'est steve a joué
une menace kg 5
ouais ouais voir ces quatre pour parer
des quatre et ça c'est hyper chaud ouais
mais justement c'est bah c'est pas si
clair non alors ça c'est pas mal et ce 1
5 kg 5 et 6 comment ce qui attend messti
faut calculer 7,5 kg 5 h 6,6 soit il y
est en tord à 8 c chiant ça ça va tout
fait vis et les cases blanches ça va
faire mal
donc du coup tu as peut-être juste pas
le temps de consolider ouais c'est
tellement dur à ce niveau là c'est
incroyable parce que tu as l'impression
que baki n'a pas fait un seul coup en
dessous et pourtant les coûts de manu
sont tellement forts adjouffou 5 bêta 4
mais ouais ça c'est dommage d'avoir joué
4 en fait je pense que magnus il l'a
compris il a provoqué f4 pas il a
compris que f4 était pas un bon coup
mais en vrai c'est compliqué à
comprendre parce que mine de rien tu as
la possibilité de jouer 5 mai c'est à
cause de ces 4 3 8 que ça avec ça
fonctionne paris
aïe il n'y a pas de dames g4 à cause du
c4 aussi f5 ayari monde ça marche pas de
la pjj et 4 ces quatre cavaliers f6 quoi
je suis ta match 4 je suis 100 j'en suis
non pas des canons
c'est marc loubry malheureusement ça ne
marche pas ouais on se fait trop quatre
aides faussaient eux mais dommage je
pense qu'il doit je sais 4 du coup pour
éviter
mais alors c'est très dur à jouer c4 c4
soi-même pour éviter ces quatre en fait
et si le moindre mal chance donc bas qui
jouent pour la nulle maintenant en vrai
si je comprends bien ouais c'est
complexe en cette position assez
terrible ce f4
on nous dit la fusion ton en faveur du
second malheureusement c'est exact exact
après c'est pas fini voilà mais c'est
vrai que ça tourne mal et c'est pas
mérité originale au vu des coûts que sa
tante si mal en fait que saiki autant
menace si si direct sur la position
d'ubs acquis par un petit un petit tweet
à félicitations à mme agnès person pour
avoir gagné cette coupe du monde
salut l'ami fascinant pas tout à fait
tweet tweet aide renvoyèrent jeu
obligèrent à l'est
c'est pas encore partie parce qu'il
manque une émeute à l'aller mode qui va
se présenter
j'ai envoyé ça y est le tweet qui est
parti pas le choix
pas le choix malheureusement un peu le
choix le choix
les mots se tient sa place à bari 1 c
c'était obligatoire lors du jason kidd
et f5 quand même à peut-être faut quand
même faire f 5 un mois je pense c'est
4,5 et va reprendre ses 4 c'est ça le
problème
aux grands maux les grands remèdes c'est
exactement ça ah oui mais si l'anti
profondeur 17 oui oui ptête il veut ça
et le tour à huit baies 3 en fait en
vrai ça
as peut-être ouais ouais bah non sap à
une belle tête mais assez une belle tête
nulle part mais ça peut ne pas perdre
tout de suite on va bien complexe oh et
puis en plus c'est ça qui est très dur
c'est qu'il faut trouver maintenant une
série de coups quasiment introuvable en
fait c'est ça qui est incroyable c'est
bizarre qu'il ait joué 4 et qui bloque
juste après en fait on s'est rendu
compte de l'erreur juste après l'avoir
joué c'est ça je pense ouais complexe
complexe complexe malheureusement pour
baky rats qui réalise tellement
quasiment la partie parfaite quoi c'est
ça qui saoule
c'est que ça joue bien et il dit quoi le
cc si on peut nous dire dans le chatt
puisque la lui doit mais c'est ça qui
est dommage en fait c'est que voilà
position était tellement agréable et en
fait soudainement si ça tourne mal et en
fait ça tourne mal peut-être
ouais c'est le g3 est d'accord c'est
récent que cette hormone
mais bon après c'est pas fini et puis
mine de rien le présent encore pas mal
de temps il se trouvait il peut trouver
des ailes peut trouver des coûts et
voilà le maquis ce qu'il ya du tour
c'est un qui peut être proposé pour
pouvoir pour pu avoir le tour à 8 mais
bon un tour c'est un an ce sera pas joui
sera pas joué c'est impossible
est ce que c'est c'est cdn 00 profondeur
56 non ça c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
ouais ça ça va mais non mais non
hilton non compressé maiden coups
précédents mais il a dû buggé quand je
vais les regarder
tu vas aller regarder moi même à il a
buggé elle ne doit pas aimer ici je
pense mais magnus il a quand même été
sacrément impressionnant web à ses
dépositions qui qui joue bien qui
maîtrise totalement
allez le prez faut jouer un coup dans
tous les cas au pire cliquer au hasard
moi j'espère wesh wesh simple non
j'espère ce cadre qu'elle réfléchisse
etienne c'est bien il se désunit pas
dans l'effort
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe le bas qui en sueur
or l'attendait un de toute façon ce
match avec impatience ce choc la finale
avant l'heure le match qualificatif pour
le championnat du bugue existants et m'a
ému ce qui a l'air confiant maintenant
ah ouais c'est que la position a bien
tourné
il est impressionnant quand même un
champion du monde et ça doit être dur
hein quand tu es en face parce que c'est
vrai qu'ils envoient que la première
ligne en fait à magnus
c'est ça la la c'est là c'est fort c'est
pas tant les derniers coups sont forcés
avant en fait ouais ouais non ils
envoient il envoie première ligne
première ligne premières lignes du futur
vide ou da à y bien regarder syncoor
mais bon oui non ça c'est le total
tabataba et ouais donc 34 idf 5 pour
résoudre les problèmes de façon
dynamique l'air de bien jouer a
réellement fait d'os dans déjà parlé
mais la garde à vue c'est vraiment fort
et le dernier séchante landes donc et
bassiste était joué c'est ça on va voir
si tu la position de monde discutaient
complexe à complet un peu complexe pour
la championnat et baky qui a réussit pas
à la trouver à trouver un coup ouais
c'est pas facile là t'as pas de solution
facile tu peux en fait si tu joues
facile là les trois prochains combats de
super la partie facile
takeshi pas que des choix difficiles way
terrible ah ouais après c'est sûr
qu'avoir magnus dans le dans un tableau
qualificatif pour les candidats moi j'ai
trouvé ça un peu étrange je te le dis
franchement maxime j'en ai souvent parlé
pour moi le règlement mais la revoir
mais bon c'est une autre question après
c'est pas contre magnus en lui il
applique le règlement il a bien raison
de jouer s'il en al'envie mais c'est
vrai que sur un média mais il y avait eu
pire il y avait eu l'île de man 2019 ou
les deux joueurs qui n'avaient pas leur
place d'un point de vue sportif c'est
elle manu63 n'avait été payée
bonjour alors ça c'est d'être par
l'organisateur barça fit mais alors là
on obtenait un truc invraisemblable
alors marcher sur la tête
oui on l'a déjà c'est dans le règlement
il ya un truc qui va pas mais mais oui
là c'est encore pire est surtout qu'en
plus ils ont quand même indiqué que
justement les grands prix fils ne
seraient pas ouverts aux joueurs déjà
qualifiés donc à partir de là ils ont
saisi une partie du problème mais
visiblement ils vont pas au bout des
choses
ouais ouais non c'est pas honnêtement
c'est pas c'est pas logique quoi y'a un
truc qui va pas surtout qui donne zéro
plats salés l'eau donc c'est vraiment
très pénalisant là pour la peine c'est
complexe donc food & cie jouer bas qui
qu'ils vouent toujours pas à ça les
disques il a joué on voit pas tout le
temps la cam
il a joué damage 5 maintenant il est un
peu à contretemps baky dans cette partie
mais il veut cavaliers g5 c'est pas si
facile ces quatre t4 f5 et surtout est
là c'est pas mal ça se voit
ça peut être aussi dramatique kg 5
mais d'ailleurs oui c'était la ligne que
je voulais jouer avant une fois que
justement quelque 3 8
c'est le tour à 8 mois qui faisait mal
mais bon l'ordi pas catastrophé tu vas
te fait cavaler hk tu peux mettre
laurent f2 tu colmate ouais ouais
après ça va être désagréable mais à dire
sale mérite entre guillemets que le
cavaliere 4 est inattaquable pour
l'instant c'est le seul mérite de
l'opposition c'est le gros problème
c'est qu'on peut jamais faire foubert et
à tour croire et si on bouge latour bas
du cou pourra pas ramené l'autre ac
c'est bête parce que ce x 2 la cca
c'est pas facile à voir ce thème quand
même deux tours qui revient à 8 non non
un serbe puis si les doigts bien manier
ces points fort no way et la sueur d'un
f3 j'imagine dame s est simplement voir
dames 3 3 ça va rentrer colonies et
après on peut même avoir des tours à 6
et âme à huit étapes et là bas enfin la
la c'est magnus qui a les cartes en main
en fait soit magnus trouver y gagne soit
il trouve pas eh ben ça va sortir voilà
s'il trouve ses 85 ch qui trouve la
suite ça va être très compliqué alors à
temps ces quatre si tu prends ces quatre
traits t'as pas envie parce que tu as ça
ouvre la south diagonale suivant
émettons j'aime bien la lever 5
ok ça c'est peut-être une vraie idée si
c'était
l'idée de baky ça paraît tarabiscoté
quand même mais bon si tu comprends le
tour à 8 et où tu peux la voir dans ton
règne
oui c'est ça tu peux l'avoir par
élimination et c'est important de
commencer comme ça par ses calculs sur
dalle béton b5
il ya besoin de prendre des 3 es tu peux
pas reprendre le j'illustre ta pensée et
sur foot dessin qui auraient des deux
noms après damas 53 foot dessin et la d2
j'imagine annonce que cette couche
lavable en fait ouais c'est gestion des
deux il y avait sept
c'est ça ça me rend fou c'est 5 en vrai
on ne pouvait pas faire pousser cinq ici
parce qu'ils avaient dame prend et on
protège et la dame
ok ok bon mais c'est rassurant puisque
si l'appui on prend puis on prend dame b
5 c'est loin d'être fait en fait c'est
ça il faut qu'ils les quoi disons qu'il
faut avoir le tour de tours à huit enfin
deux variantes
c'était ça et c'est compliqué parce que
en fait je me suis fait c'est compliqué
c'est que tu donnes cette diagonale et
via dame b 5 puis l'alcool matin peu
visible pour ça que c'est possible
l'abbé sinclair c'est très difficile si
bas qu'il trouve c'est qu'il est
vraiment en grande forme
en tout cas il s'est levé
ça c'est déjà bien il va un peu se
détendre et aller un peu alors peut-être
assez important de se détendre après moi
je dis ça je dis rien maxime mais il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé entre le
g3 f4 et le damage 5 via un tweet qui
est parti il ya un coefficient de
friction eu un tweet ça ça peut changer
des choses
et oui d'ailleurs et tombe bien sûr que
ma guise va trouver ses 4 après ce tweet
on n'est pas sûr pour là il peut partir
sur du fou dessine kholoud ses parois
suite pour la suite d'être inscrit pour
moi je suis ça ferait plaisir
le tweet en vrai même hier il a fait des
les mauvais effets parce que en fait bas
qui était complètement foutu dans ce
format de lens on a chip qui gagne et
toi tu étais plutôt me
et du coup c'est inverser les tendances
des matchs qu a atteint en fait un super
du tweet web
d'ailleurs je t'envoie la facture c'est
la première fois belles truites avaient
mis bien contre par avion quand même
temps bien qu'on ne paradis en vrai moi
j'étais pas du tout inquiet alors après
cette frustrante papa conclure mais
j'étais pas du tout entier revient
ouais c'est ça ça aurait plus se plier
même plutôt le match en vrai c'est petit
goûter était en danger ce dans une
partie tavel et blanc où l'appui de
faire un tour aux cinq fromages trois
tours h5 mais qui était dur à voir
ouais bon magnus en sueur par la bac il
est revenu il est imposant mcillroy
l'échiquier je trouve vraiment vraiment
en confiance et il est vraiment assis à
bien ouais dans ma nièce qui réfléchit
qui va sans doute jouer ces quatre quand
même parce que c'est du coup naturelle
celle qu'on a envie de jouer mais après
est-ce qu'il a la suite c'est alors déjà
est ce qu'il a dépensé 4 et md5 est-ce
qu'il a la suite c4 des quatre f5 et kg
5 mach 1 h 6 ça la question c'est ce
qu'il a toutes les suites à jusqu'au
bout
c'est ça et à mon avis ce n'est pas le
cas on verra réd façon y'a plus qu'à
attendre on peut plus faire grand chose
c'est ça le temps et puis si ici ma
demie joue c4 on attend le des français
4 à tempo pour montrer quand même qu'il
peut être un as il peut il peut il peut
il peut le faire mais qui peut le faire
aller c'est maintenant à s'élancer le
16h35 baky pâquis pas qui pas kibaki bas
qui bat chiba kibaki
baky petit maquis sahara qui bat qui
bavent richie battu battu battu battu
battu battu patty attendre à des petits
bas qui comme ça il va nous attendre la
télé loin d'inscire quoi un kilomètre en
leçons il porte jusque là facilement
même pas même pas un kilomètre
il a joué dams et 6 aïe aïe aïe le
saumon le sou ou alors à temps est-ce
que c'est la bonne nouvelle ou pas ah
bah oui ça peut être qu'une bonne
nouvelle 5.4 déjà c4 c4
il va faire quoi b4 et weight a coupé
trois tunnels soit 4 avec gain de temps
oui tu reviens un peu quand même ray et
sûrs et turcs contenir la colonie en
plus ouais pas être cool à 1 on envisage
que la victoire pour le joueur
pakistanais tard h 3à non au nom ça
j'aime pas
aulas et qu'at-il fait mal maintenant ah
ouais non anaya y aie aie aie en plus
trop vite trop rapide
pourquoi il a fait ça tempo bas qui il
n'a pas vu le c4 ah ouais mais là c'est
bizarre ces quatre 16.5 ou pas d'autres
temps plus non puissent quand il ya la
dame ans et ça brise
après ils avaient peut-être pas l'idée
de jouer ces quatre essais après un bref
c'est calcin coûterait contre intuitif
pour les blancs mais tu vois que tu es
un peu de temps je reviens j'ai d'autres
x a donc du coup là si les noirs je sais
que tu dois avoir une idée bas qui il
veut peut-être faire des quatre f5 et
cavaliers f2 est bloqué c'est complexe
est là ça va arriver de partout en fait
alors là ça va être terrible
il était si proche
ainsi l'on ferme le damage contre lui ça
n'est pas bien placé saddam mais surtout
pourquoi je vous aussi lite
je sais pas combien de temps il a mimé
trans ou non max je vais te dire ça
alors dit l'ami juste à tempo tempo je
vais mettre un refresh c'est à dire que
c'est arrivé pendant la concaténation
des coûts donc c'est qu'il a dû jouer en
moins de 30 secondes vraie seconde picot
scop
mais c'est ça mais surtout en fait c'est
c4 tapant le jeu tap en vip look et on
fume et on fout il va se faire bloquer
en fait ouais mais du coup c'est qu'à ça
permettait de sécuriser le pion détroit
quoi pour sécuriser le cavalier alors
après peut-être qu'en fait banier avait
ses quatre des quatre dames c6 damage 3l
5 kgs f2 ils espéraient tenir il est
oublié tour à 8 tonnes ça et du coup il
s'est dit ça change rien après
adams est dommage c'est que même toi f6
fait mal en fait le truc c'est que tous
aillent mal à s'asseoir
ah bah oui la taça diagonale à qui fait
mal le pion plus ce qui sert à rien
après ces quatre ça paraissait bien pour
l'activité du foulon banon mais ça
marchait pas ce que tu as sauvé trois
gagnants dans cette fois 4 ouais c'est
pas évident c mais bon ça veut dire
qu'ils avaient probablement pas laisser
un tel que j'ai c'est un thème que j'ai
déjà vu il n'avait pas le sait le thé le
dcb ces dames besbes à ceux qui la bat
nancy j'avais il aurait pas à mr
jeannerot temp aurait donc pas de regret
par rapport à ça
non vraiment plus d'un match moi je vois
pas vraiment ce qu'il veut en fait
surtout que la joie pas de cas ou manier
joue pas ces 4 alors ces câbles des
français quatre ménages imagine quand
même fou c'est 5 va c'est horrible même
pas envie de regarder en fait
bizarrement d'être un petit espoir mais
bon piont français quatre ans évidemment
et maintenant tu as plus du tout ces
jeunes des cinq a laissé jouer ces
quatre c'était la cote
elle va falloir un autre tweet en bas je
sais pas si c'est des trucs peuvent
sauver la maxime malheureusement non non
ça c'est le coup de bambou trop forte
côté magnus un trop fort allo président
le président qui n'écoute pas les
conseils kingdon ans a aussi un genre
bien réfléchir au hasard oui mais mais
après pas au bout devant ce contre quoi
alors wikio rasoir bien sûr mais après
réflexion il peut pas faire cavaler
prendrait six sur la c'est comme s'ils
n'avaient pas le clic irizar il pensait
d'un match trop et des forces et donc du
coup ils ont raison quand il fait d'un
lâche 3 à ces six celle qui peut jouer
ces quatre que là il va se mettre
cliquer au hasard voilà il va se prendre
ça ça ça ça et ça ouais et ça va mater
pour pour magnus
c'est terrible après je ne peux pas dire
qu'il fasse une mauvaise partie non plus
bas qui avaient magnus en face qui est
vraiment impressionnant
bien sûr la presse et c'est dommage
dommage dommage on va faire cavalier il
va faire des cartes et cavaliers f2
c'est sûr c'est surtout le timing en
fait qui me déprime
le timing du damage trois thèmes
pourquoi tu n'as même pas laissé le
temps d'entre eux a alors à temps tout
est ce qu'il a oublié cd4 f5 koubéens
voulait foulée un média tour dès le 8 à
dire que j'aurais pensé touré fuite en
prime cinq qui tu as oublié tour de huit
possibles à ce nouveau doublé un truc
pareil
hu si c'était son idée pas si sûr un
fait si c'était une idée après dames
c'est 6 de jeu d'un match 3 ça veut dire
que c'est le truc qui voit de très loin
ouais alors il a juste oublié 3,8 mais
en tout cas clairement il est d'être
dans l'élite et ses cadres des quatre de
ses six damage 3 en fait
oui oui non c'est sûr elle aurait pas
jouer tempo connaissant baky c'est un
coût qui l'avait pas envisagée répond
jamais tempo voilà je crois qu'il a
compris à baky ouais mais là c'est sûr
qu'il a compris en fait quand tu joues
tu combien à un moment donné où tu
comprends quoi quand on vous le coup et
que ça va plus il ya un mental non bah
c'est terrible
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre quand il
faut faire un mur de quelque chose mais
je sais pas quoi bah les barbelés non ah
bah oui les barbelés le chéneau meilhan
barbe de miettes
je débarque ya que les barbelés qui
peuvent aider mais ça va être complexe
il ya déjà eu le nul 1 2 tab à tabac et
feydeau cf nul vie dit tout annuler il
reste champion car yakine en fait de
thèse et baky non mais en fait j'ai
compris on la lance est trop tard le mur
de barbelés
alors on n'a pas eu trop le temps aussi
ajouté mme peau c'est vrai oui mais on
aurait dû lancer après quatre peut-être
ça aurait pu aider
ouais donc fluidité les champions deux
fois là un pied ça ça peut tourner des
deux côtés se distingue par les cieux
cavalier blanc annoncé 4 ou pas et donc
on a pas on n'a pas malheureusement de
deux fours b1 parce qu on se fait
matraquer comme je suis en train de le
montrer à l'écran terrible
c'est terrible est le caleçon sorte de 6
n'a pas n'a pas tari à cette passion il
la patrie qui au hasard en fait deux
matches qu'on a oublié cliquer au hasard
et qu'il avait le droit de cliquer
ouazar ouais c'était arrive ça sans
abandon alors celle là là ça sent ça
sent la bande ont effectivement y'a pas
moyen en fait non là y'a pas moyen je
pense c'est vraiment bête quoi je vois
pas de mon doux ou saas au nom ben c'est
ça ouais on puisse les 85 y ait deux
packs 3,8 mais en plus tour à 8 se
serait vu bah oui parce que je pense que
non seulement se seraient vus mais s'est
jouée par lampiris qua non mais bien sûr
bien sûr c'est pas c'est pas dur le
rigolo en face à ces magnus carlsen
ouais parce que il avait calculé le loin
en fait et ça quand on calcule de loin
on peut faire des erreurs
[Musique]
le prêt sera suffisamment plat mais un
surhomme
en fait on fait tous cette erreur après
un maximum en fait tu es obligé de
calculer de loin et puis quand tu t'es
trompé dans ton calcul en fait la faute
à l'arrivée à un endroit ou un autre ne
peut pas tout recalculer à chaque et
c'est ça et puis il faut avoir la
lucidité à certains moment de se dire je
re calcul ce qui se passait alors il a
joué un coup il a joué dès 4 ans
on va le voir
j'avais pas la cam du coup voilà magnus
et en cas faudrait comité magnus c'est
quand le prochain test
c'est le jour des départage mai mais on
peut le forcer à avoir des symptômes dès
demain terrible praia le cac au vide
encore qu'il peut sauver
il a fait des quatre baky même 3,8
d'efforts ça c'est terrible mais bon ce
sera avec cinq tours à 8 c 46 en fait tu
penses que baky va tenté de la défendre
longtemps où ça peut il a tenté mais il
va tenter de la défense mais ces deux
patients savent pas sa fin si ça craque
ça craque un parce que là ça paraît
tellement dur à jouer avec les blancs
[Musique]
n'arriva pas de chacun ici ouais ouais
ouais
si est-ce qu'on peut appeler ça une
bonne nouvelle en fait c'est qui qui va
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme coup en fait
est-ce que six nouvelles quoi faire bref
deux camps même en vrai mais la dame f3
ouais c'est dégueulasse aussi prise
prise tour f 1 6 6 2 voilà ce temps pour
elle de damas chamakh s'est déjà rsa
s'est terminée ce qui peut faire qu'à
relief deux dames f 3 tours 5
ah oui ne brisez de 3,8
pardon way s'est instantanément mort ça
aussi yacoub et rend la technique ça
passera pas
et ce qui peut prendre un v6 ouais c'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire je pense mais
mais c'est vrai ça va pas tenir ça donne
des cinq fours b1 comme ça mais bon on
voit bien que ça peut pas tenir un nom
ça peut pas tenir la dame est condamné
en restant h3 et ouais ça fini puis ça
finit toujours par craquer ces trucs là
il faut regagner bourse et là c'est la
seule chance c'est un temps fou jean
tura 8g si ces tours à 2,6 il faut
jeunesse tu veux jouer et carrier g5 en
nous proposant le chat est bon je sais
juste et surtout pékin j'imagine non kg
5 1 avec la louve mais elles cinq civils
et qui a valu à ercis damage 7 matt
sayles un cui lecavalier et repart et
sema direct oui j'ai eu un coût non mais
là il ya plus de wayne il ya plus de
défense envahit va tenter back in the
sky et kingson
non là c'est impossible de défendre aïe
aïe aïe c'est la douche froide
c'est la douche froide
non là ya pas de bail à plus de monde
j'y crois plus du tout la maxime
honnêtement
un mirage ouais ben là c'est plus que du
miracle je sais bien la forêt vraiment
une gaffe ou une absence de magnus et
shankland en vrai c'est complexe
[Musique]
c'est très solide en guerrier qu'il
allait se jouer l'esprit je sais pas
ensuite tour au 50 rue
et puis espérer
ouais c'est peut-être ça qui donne les
meilleures chances au final sur dame
civis pris la tête du tour euh ouais non
tenter ça et puis et puis voir ce qui se
passe il va élever y vas tu faire de
façon ces deux échecs dames à charef de
damas le problème c'est que tu bouges
plus les pièces mais bon après ça va
demander à trouver un coude entre 11,5
et déjà enfant et puis l'info trouve un
où tu m'as jouets poupées 1 au prochain
si tu as le temps de ta fougue et un
pouce et 2,31 donc tu as quand même fait
deux fois fort fou j'ai deux voilà voilà
et là tu es mieux avoir ce que fait bac
est issu issue bateau-feu tenter sa 100%
100% saas tentes et c'est pour ça que
tour des huit tels que peut-être une on
va dire une moins pire nouvelle comparé
à f/5 qui oula tu pouvais pas prendre
des systèmes est ce qu'il va être en des
6 et 3 6 1 suivant ouais ça donne ça
donne cette petite option
allez à l'état les instantes si le trou
je reprends 8% espoir ok s'il le trouve
froid 0 paris lors d'une autre refus
d'une cavale et des deux noms en justice
contre au niveau quoi en fait à elle
veut mettre le roi en f2 et très froid
je vois bien mais problème c'est que
l'adil trop passif
ok mais c'était pas si cons peut-être y
en a certains monde au sud quand échange
les tours talent fou peu inquiets
protéger j'ai pas tout permettre leur en
e1 le font bien et tout protéger ouais
non qu'ils aient tous un coup aussi
moitié des 200 qui donne espoir à paris
propose un pion tu wen a fait cette mare
à l'autre est quand même un bon ça va
être foutu aussi amer il joue pas mais
je pars loin ce n'était pas pour 2,8 ce
n'était pas optimale du coup pour
essayer de provoquer des accidents des
soupers inde et rue
ouais ouais ouais fouka et des deux si
jamais le d5 truc c'est qu'il faut qu'il
prenne une décision parce que là il a
plus de temps baki mais si ça se noie
pas l'accuser pas avoir réfléchi sur en
jouant des matches trop hélas de trop
réfléchir non un moment faut qu'ils
réfléchissent et qu'ils trouvent le bon
coup car il a vraiment la tête dans les
mains il a réfléchi à 200%
ouais bon allez un bac il faut trouver
le coup le seul l'unique le plan il ce
temps dit pas qui mais bon il est pas
spécialement entendu tendu et c'est
juste qu'ils donnent tous là il fait
l'effort pour trouver pour trouver des
pompiers il a encore dans l'ascension il
est dans les pentes raides un bon coup
ouais bon a plus qu'à attendre comme
d'habitude c'est comme quand on regarde
tu es parti en fait on attend souvent
les coups non c'est vrai qu'à suivre les
rapides c'est plus plus excitant on va
falloir se pencher sur la question de
pas être enroulé élimination directe je
veux dire même si on détourne
réalisation cuffaut 16,1 d'un loser
bracket un machin ou tuera un double
double élimination chez trituraf is a
way valeur après le problème c'est qu'il
voyait encore à 16 4 tours situées fait
sur trois jours ça te fait 7 14
en fait et en plus davantage que le
temps mis le plus de joueurs etc
tu peux dire ok ce qu'ils perdent tout
est rentré chez vous si et quand même
voilà un des gros avantages par rapport
à un tournoi ou alors après évidemment
les tie breaks en parts
si rapide si on chante pas tout le monde
hein non plus mais mais je pense que
c'est ok au tennis c'est fou
l'élimination directe hormis le masters
d'abord mais en fait c'est tout le temps
comme ça tous les torts à sion comme ça
après les championnats de foot sont pas
vraiment comme ça les championnats
domestiques en tout cas et c'est parce
que t'es trop décrypte aussi c'est parce
que c'est différent fins et voilà ça
joue sur toute l'année ça se joue pas
sur deux trois semaines quoi ah
ouais mais écoutez etienne qui
réfléchiront sait pas exactement quand
il a le temps parce que quand j'ai mis
des refresh s'armer le temps à 0 mais il
doit pas dû rester masse de temps ici
très clairement zen de minutes une
quinzaine de minutes
il va arriver à prendre une décision là
dans les cinq dix minutes qui viennent
au plus tard il gardera cinq minutes tu
penses après ton temps qu'il trouve pas
le coup il est obligé de réfléchir à
agir il peut passer tout ce qu'ils
voient ça perd il obligeait de qui je
pense le cavalier des deux ans j'ai pas
mangé mais bien il est il est plus
marlou peut-être que les autres c'est ça
et d'entraînement ou après c'est facile
de trouver les coûts pendant un certain
temps les noirs mais après tu es un plan
où tu te remets en scène à voir demain
chilipari fils sont réfléchies ce temps
là au moment du damage 3 ce qui l'aurait
trouvé ces 4 uniquement c4eva y avait
plusieurs coups damage 3 c'était
vraiment pas une belle chose
les systèmes de ronde suisse ne pourrait
pas se prêter autour des chagos c'est ce
qu'on fait en général en fait ouais bon
allez
à l'eba qui je vais jouer
allez il faut vraiment jouer un coup
maintenant assez complexe et complexe
pour etienne et manuscrits en confiance
un ça se voit il est complètement
décontracté maintenant c'est que il sait
qu'il a quelques doigts quelques
quelques encablures d'une victoire et de
la demi finale
il faut cliquer au hasard l'a peut-être
sa chance
oui mais s'il pèche pas par orgueil
comment certains présidents contre ravi
voilà tu penses magnus qu'il essaierait
de gagner avec les blancs ou pas wiz
khalifa jouera plus juste se qualifier
perso moi dans la configuration actuelle
des choses oui parce que ça lui garantit
une journée de repos aussi et puis ça
lui assure une fin là il est vraiment
proche de la fin quoi salua sur la place
en demies oui oui
après il y aura le vainqueur de duda vie
dites donc c'est normalement un match où
là encore à sa portée et dans le tableau
de l'autre côté maintenant il n'y a plus
qu'eux car yakine à mon avis qu'il
inquiète vraiment qui sort sa game
même si c'est sans doute pas mieux pour
les blancs le statut lui qui est du bon
coup du bon côté de la poussette
grasset long d'attendre quand c'est
comme ça avec mes coups mais là la celle
inverse
parce qu'ils aient ce qui était cool
dans les tours d'avancé comme y avait
deux joueurs en fait on suivait baky et
toi et du coup on tournait un peu d'un
côté de l'autre donc quand il y avait
des temps d'arrêt comme salle on pouvait
voir les jeter un oeil est tous là là
malheureusement là malheureusement on
n'a plus bas qui est du coup on est
obligé d'attendre une époque d'ailleurs
pour revenir sur les formats il avait
fait la fille d'une série tournoi
l'ajustement rapide pour le coup et en
élimination directe dont qu'ils avaient
compris ça ya trente ans mais ensuite il
avait abandonné le formes bizarres on
dit le temps s'écoule quand même quand
un joueur part ah bah oui bien sûr à
aller il nous faut le coup allez le coup
aller le coup de baky le kit l'échiquier
qui ne peuvent pas arrêter la pendule en
attendant pas comme ça ce serait très
mal ou pourtant à la tentation il reste
dix minutes il va falloir se décider là
il va le rester si tu es à la wii là ça
devient urgent de trouver le coup silva
show qui était deux je pense qu'après
une telle réflexion peut jouer des idées
ou alors il
bêtement imploser la cessoie gérant chez
pas géants sonne je trouve pas un coup
au milieu c'est soit tu trouves le coût
soit ample aux quoi et genre en trois
quatre coups tu perds tout cas ils
hésitent là en fait il a il a tous les
coups non c'est juste que il choisit
c'est juste qu'ils choisiraient a banni
c'est qu'il est pas bien et qui doit
voir un moyen de colmater cette vente
diagonale en fait ouais à l'iref chi min
et il a toujours pas joué on attend face
on est obligé de prendre la décision
dans les quelques minutes à venir
elle attend le refresh de la boutique
elle fait le chèque alors encore s'y
perd aujourd'hui lors encore une petite
chance demain mais à vrai dire avec les
noirs contre carl scène se serait de
l'ordre du miracle non je voulais jouer
la partie auquel cas il y aura un petit
espoir messi mais je ne peux pas ne pas
s'emmerder ok y'a juste ça n'existe pas
de gagner une deuxième portier rhénan
sur commande déjà et jacques contre
banus mais c'est à dire que si magnus
est dans la situation inverse pas
beaucoup de partis qui peut gagner
d'ailleurs il n'avait été dans la
situation inverse en 2010 shanxi il a
une pas gagné du tout quoi
le coût de ce hard off c'est peut-être
sa part peut-être de la foire duquel
sont français le pouvoir du caleçon là
très clairement
donc tu aimes pas s'il est ouest et s'il
a vu ce cavalier non cessibles a pu
skier s'était jusque là montrée size
ça fout ici roi f1 et peut-être ça tient
non ça ça va et donc du coup la ligne
c'est adam riess non mais ne faut pas
trop regarder la petite turbine est
c'est juste qu'elle a épousé en mai mais
moins celle concernant l'attitude vis ne
faut pas trop lui faire confiance dame b
6-3 f1 vous prend des cinq cavaliers f6
gf dame gk3 je suis tarif 5
c'est la ligue kata récent des cinq ans
vrai ouais c'est peut-être objectivement
le meilleur alors après friendship même
là ça va être très longue souffrance et
sans trop perspective mais oui c'est le
alors pourquoi son compte vers celui
fleurs fugate damas bah ouais non après
tu défends mais bon t'as toujours le
problème du x 2 etc
mais oui tu peux jouer dans les trois
mois j'ai 2 etc
ah oui voilà f5 et là je sais pas par
esprit et ça en fait ça j'ai jamais fait
face est malheureusement roi g2 ils sont
algérois jetteront tuque un sort bien
mais moi ça ok ce l'énergie terrestre
des 5 c'est peut-être le coup clutch
peut-être que que magnus a raté cet idf
si ça veut dire que tu la vois
ah bah oui mais c'est la puissance du
caleçon à al ayyat le caleçon le caleçon
qui peut sauver la sphère rallied à tous
comment il a le caleçon il a le tweet il
a tout son côté -4 avait moins 4 ou ses
batailles pièce de plus là si c'est
moins 424 où ils se trouvent et suit
avec consécutive alors je peux te
montrer là comme cc marche c'est moins 4
après d'anne decis roi f1
fou des cinq cavaliers ici je vais
mettre la ligne de cessez quoi gf
d'alger qu'à trois fuites c'est bien ça
la ligne dames f5 et la norme est ok et
ses x 3 l'a89 ou bien quand même qui
menacent match alors après j'imagine
qu'un problème doit être qui doit
s'appeler tour en échec
ouais mais bon ça veut dire que faut
penser à foix iii il faut calculer de
parts non mais ça tu trouves pas dans la
partie fois trois fois trop c'est dur
fauntroy c'est pas naturel
est ce que ça peut être un exercice à
genre de baky cette position là si la
vue est flou à 3 à ça peut être un
exercice ils s'y font preuve quatre très
tôt en fait ça peut être un exercice y x
3 est le bon coup et qu'on va dire vous
prend avec elle c'est ça laisse un
avantage mais ensuite faut trouver une
série de 3 4 ou derrière
ok c'est dire que là ça pourrait pas
l'être en fait ce que vous pourrez faire
4 est trop fort non parce que vous
prenez 4 on a vu que ça pouvait aussi
tourné en égalité si les noirs sont pas
précis dont peut-être ça peut être un
exercice
bon on va le garder pour baky seule
ville à oui ça va être gardé le
président qui ne sait pas ce qui lui
arrive
bon allez on l'appela il a quand même
trouvé il a trouvé une idée moi en fait
j'y croyais pas à dessein dans le sens
ça me semblait impossible à trouver ben
moi je suis croyait pas dans le sens où
et où je pensais au pire jiafu prend un
f4 et cetera mais en fait c'est pas si
la minute en plus pour magnus
donc il n'aura pas le temps de bien
poser le calcul puisque ça va arriver
dans le design autant plus être
positionné du coup way band d'instinct
gedik tour des 8es punk ou savait jouer
5 et sur dame prend pions l'a montré en
fait c'est tour d un ouais tu vas faire
pousser cinq échecs airlines pourcentage
de magnitski abaissé à son tour aller ça
part de là et dames cécile sourire
et là ça peut commencer à tournicoter
est encore chaud je reprendrai largement
les noirs mais ça va être chaud alors
peut-être quelle défense quand même de
baky qui se lève au bas qui s'élève à
voilà c'est ça qu'on veut voir
il est parti baky et magnus qui surent
garder son âme et on a bien fait de
faire ce mur de barbelés en fait je
pense qu'on en réunit siens elle est un
deuxième wii nice et à léon de barbelés
parce que là il a mis les barbelés mais
je lui rajouter des routines pense qu'un
peu de poutine peu à faut se rappeler
qu'on est à domicile des barbelés à
domicile les barbelés poutine est ce qu
aller ça peut le faire
et d'ailleurs je sais ce que je vais
faire je vais en mettre aussi sur le
chat de chester à ça ça peut largement
aidé alors moi je peux en mettre sur le
chat de chasse comme avec en plus pour
les trolls au fond avec le compte de
chasse comme france à dire en fait ils
vont pas être contents que déjà il ya
des gens qui viennent
le seul problème c'est que c'est que
chess comme france est passable du coup
je peux pas leur mettre des barbelés
avec ce conte faut que j'aille avec
l'autre compte
ouais je vais les mettre avec mon compte
perso du coup quelques petits barbelés
qui peuvent aider à temps parce que moi
j'ai la chronique chirico plus hagège
pas attaquer la carte téléphone là qui
peut t'aider à mon avis je suis trop
long par mon opérateur je n'ai pas de
catch et je l'aimé pas c'est bon c'est
bon c'est bon ils sont partis sont
partis ils sont partis ils sont partis
je quitte vite ce stream
voilà ça va être quittaient
immédiatement mais les barbelés sont
venus se présenter quand même il n'y
avait pas le choix
allez il faut que bakiev ogba qui serre
la vis
il peut s'y tient là nul ça va
un coup psychologique à magnus en gros
il aura dix ans magnus et a été mieux
mais je suis plus fort que toi
dans le chat que tu les avais arrêté les
barbelés et des réveils à wade ils ont
en quelque sorte quelque sorte en
quelque sorte mais c'est pas moi en
quelque sorte bras mais ils ont
l'habitude du public français qui vient
de ça et là elle est là ils ont pu le
chat de cha ce cadre ils sont dégoûtés
là bas c'est le beau rien dit à la
presse qui a raté ses 4 mais qui trouve
des cinq qui étaient beaucoup plus en
plus basse parce qu'il a jouée est aim
paul daraîche 3 mais voila voila ca est
de réfléchir complet gauche mais je vais
pouvoir le troll un peu le président ce
soir surtout si perds tu trolles panne
on and on s'y perd tu trolles pas en bas
6 nuls y sera trop de retenue le troll
je pense à 6 nuls il va être content là
ce soir ça ça peut vraiment lui donner
un surplus de confiance pour demain à
mon avis il l'air il va me demander s'il
a joué une bonne partie du tout vla de
ringgold la partie plate se demande
pourquoi tu joues encore voilà jean
pierre fabre qui passent dans fakir par
un petit suis le petit suis et qui sut
miami chat qui est passé aussi voir tout
à l'heure ah non mais c'était il est là
et la fête il est vraiment là ouais
c'est bien sûr on est bien à cannes en
ce moment fait beau et tout c'est sympa
c'est sympa à bali et l année dernière
et oui je me rappelle s'était passé là
cette année ça tombe mal
cette année ça tombe très mal c'est
complexe
l âge et même pas le droit de venir en
france c'est terrible ouais ouais non
mais ça c'est enfin c'est un club que la
france ô sur liste rouge et la russie
n'ont en fait
sa marge à l'économique en fait ouais en
vrai après le problème c'est qu'il faut
pas trop le chart parce que autant y
vont pas remettre la france sur
l'histoire mais sont capables de cela la
russie sur liste oui si on parle trop
fort ah oui pourtant empêché de
participer à et pas que moi ça que tu
avec le toit pour être quasiment éliminé
manu les noms s'y met la russie sur
liste rouge jusqu'en soit noyé personne
quoi tu auras tout le monde fuit la
vapeur se demander par exemple comment
aniche vient oui non mais t'as personne
qui vient fait déjà la neige comme on y
vient on sait pas mais je ne viens pas
clore mon avis ah ouais bah déjà il est
censé jaune rapide mais mes toiles
rapide tu joues par non bah après
peut-être qu'ils peuvent trouver une
solution moi je veux pas le rapidement
solution ou en gros ils font des
exceptions pour les sportifs quoi un peu
comme à lille et subban en tout cas
clairement ils m'ont dit que c'était
compliqué parce que sinon ils auraient
eu leur est fait pour moi aussi que la
fin ça sympa automatique et du cou
et ça fait pas partie des exceptions
près pour l' us open de tj imagine que
si une exception mais alors et encore
parce que les tous ceux qui vont arriver
aux us vient enfin il y en a beaucoup
qui viendront du japon ou alors bon je
sais pas et du coup tu sais toi c'est si
j'avais et avait par exemple j'ai une
bêtise à aniche qui peut pas jouer qu'on
ne propose du coup d'être une carte pour
le rapide tu accepterais ou pas ou
justaret pas envie de jouer genre
bon j'imagine que ça arrivera pas c'est
pour ça que je pose la question parce
qu'il ya une chance sur mille que ça
arrive pas impossible peu probable mais
pas impossible
après si tu es sur place du maine
pourquoi pas eu ça me prend dé 5,1 ça
trop ça troll de plus en plus là ça va
jouer là à temps j'ai peur qu'il avait
calé prend des six en fait vers l'avant
mais a peut-être eu tour à aider avant
alors à temps oui tout raté 1.4 ess qui
la surprend s à manier style agissent
adam ok mais surtour vitia pas tout rose
un nom surtout reif 8 bat appel chouette
a pas de choix et surtout reprendre et 6
à tours l2 maths ça c'était pour montrer
et surtout c'est ça ouais ça c'est
facile c'est matt aussi mais tour 5-6
genre pas cool c'est pas genre faut
prendre cinq trois provinces mais après
objectivement évidemment tu es toujours
moins bien mais c'est tellement un
soulagement par rapport à ce que tu
avais je veux juste voir la ligne qui
donne le truc
g6 il faut un salaire choix défendre
quand même chaud mais bon c'est cadeau
c'est chaud très chaud
ouais c'est ça c'est la partie il dit
c'est nul mais non mais c'est pas du
tout nu les gars ses avantages
magnus mais probable oui non et nagui
s'appelle non j'ai vérifié s'ils se
dessiner
non le problème en fait je vois assez
créé une ligne dans l'ordi débile c'est
que là en fait ils te fais tour des 8es
sur pions prend il a touché 4 est que
mais ça faut avoir quand même
ouais tu penses il a ça il a passé
beaucoup de temps
peut-être y l'année est ce qu'il ya de
la répète oui
voir ça avec l'idée psion prend fou des
trois rois j'ai un tour heureux d'avoir
tourné huit c'est vraiment dur alentours
des 8 il à paris là ça mais ça c'est
grave ou pas si la non parce que ta dam
des singes froid après c'est dur c'est
dur mais au caire dur après c'est dur à
défendre mais d'un autre côté hockey
c'est beaucoup mieux que d'avant et puis
là il ya peut-être g4 aussi peut-être cg
qu'être triste d'un jeu les deux ça
c'est pas genre et frais at à ça tu vas
dire ouais et du coup tu à éviter les
faux f5 était en vie alors là c'est très
dur mais bon des shots a eu cette chance
allez on voit des barbelés suite à wii
puisqu'il ya eu deux trois bons coups de
magnus fo fera envoyer les barbelés
c'est chaud très chaud à maxime ouais je
sais pas du tout lâché 4 c'est dur à
trouver
ouais il a joué non je crois pas qui on
n'a pas forcément il est joué et mg de
wyclef jean
après après sa b2 c'est dur pour magnus
le tour des 8es durel fouet f5 c'est pas
sûr que ce soit gagnant-gagnant
oui mais la finale de fous où elle était
vraiment perdante à 100%
ah bah oui puisque deux fois 2 qu'il
bloquait t'as pas le temps de roide et 4
3 3 des 4 as et cinq premiers cinq
français quatre noms ouais je suis trop
c'est trop this is non je fais confiance
j'imagine c'est moi le temps que je
calcule toi tu as déjà terminé de kate a
déjà sûrement qu'elle fut la variante
avant que je l'imaginais même quoi donc
je te fais confiance
mais fo l5 faut quand même la voir aussi
ce qui là où il ya du fleuve sainthia
d'amener ça en fait tourner des beats
gagne mais alors tour des huit au caire
autour des huit noms mais il n'a pas
tant des 8,6 natondé 8 janvier
bravo la victoire des huit peut aussi
perdre théoriquement se trompe et par
contre je souhaite qu'ils la voient ça
je pense qu'il a pris en défaut et si
c'est bien ou pas après m6
ok maintenant tu peux envisager les
fours b1 déjà fou que j'ai la foi f6
bien non le 106 et fois fils et
peut-être même pas grande souffrance en
vrai vous étiez c'est un tout petit peu
moins bien alors peut-être alors
peut-être les amis en tout cas il n'est
pas sûr de lui et magnus il était sûr il
aurait déjà envoyé le coup parce qu'il
peut pas il a plus que cinq
tu peux pas avoir envie de te mettre
avec une minute trente il reste encore
cinq coups il peut y avoir des coups
encore hyper compliqué à venir ouais
donc il peut pas il peut pas vouloir ça
sinon est ce que si magnus tomber dans
les avec les 30 secondes restantes et
qu'à un moment il lui reste deux
secondes est ce que ce serait sous la
table en cendres a déjà fait ça passait
ça se passe c'est autorisé satoriz et
surtout que ça peut ça peut ne pas être
vu par la caméra tu vois tu fermes ou
sans faire exprès les caméras ne voit
pas le caractère volontaire de la chose
tu fais comme le mien et puis en plus a
pas forcément là bas on a pu s'en rendre
compte dans d'autres
renoir et oui il ya plus de quatre
minutes à l'est il a peut-être pas à
laymont maxime semnon là c'est
maintenant au tour des huit doigts
d'après ça m'inquiète y réfléchissent
c'est qu'il a rien il a rien maxime
autour des 8 c'est moins quatre lors des
huit ça fait très mal
tendez 8 ça fait très mal mais bon il va
pas la voir à temps il va jouer en
partie tu l'aurais tour des huit noms ou
là je pense que je ferais fsa j'essaye
de me convaincre
il est arrivé un truc à il avait un coup
de main pas très long quoi ouais voilà
là et là c'est le full il avait il avait
une tête à jouer tour des huit quoi il
avait un mouvement tour des huit mois je
sais pas je sens autour des 8 à la
gestuelle c'est tendu là il a il a la
main prête à partir
sur le tour des huit tu veux que je le
mette la caméra en très grand 1 d
ce cas là toute façon ça se joue à ça
ouais là ça joue plus qu'à ça oh je
crois qu'il a une fois mis en fuite par
fou il prend le football a une tête de
tour 2003 ion on peut laisser en visuel
le comme ça de toute façon alors attends
je peux faire un truc que j'avais fait
auparavant
je peux faire un visuel technologie
pakistanaise
ça c'est la technologie pakistanais
c'est beau c'est beau mais au dessus du
game c'est la fameuse technologie
baptista sont les pendus je vais pas les
mettre parce qu'on voit pas grand chose
cette zae de notes
oui et on écrirait comme satané
l'échiquier qui ces magies 28 il manque
juste le drapeau pakistanais au dessus
du prez non là on est bien là on est
bien et d'amd 5
ça c'est évidemment le seul coup et
après faut aussi se retrouver dame c'est
sans savoir ce qui fait qu'il est
concentré il à 200% place tu attends
donc du coup d'un des cinq chances
d'être ottawa f2 tour de roy gerges
entretien à temps désolé en fait j'ai du
mal à je peux pas garder les je peux pas
bouger mais chic et en même temps et oui
oui non j'ai juste mettre la flèche vers
le cou à yafa bafa qui passe la fab qui
va peut-être venir ou pas ah ouais ok
vas-y femme qui vient fermer la porte
ferme la porte à l'eba qui ouvrit à la
main ils l'auraient oui mais oui bien
sûr il ya les maquis aleba kibaki et la
roumanie il ya moins de deux minutes
x 3,6 fléchi ces jouets tempo et la
retrouver dame c'est simple je pense
ouais c'était ça sinon il ya un x 3
pouces et 5 mais ça il va l'avoir baki
ouais cette fois je crois food et 4 ça
s'est très facilement fait d'un de ses
cinq s'efforcer et surtout prend b2
tyson j'imagine par contre ce qui va
être dur ces dames 65.3 rêve de fou b2i
la photo vg cas ça c'est plus complexe
mais bon chaque chose en son temps là
déjà dame ses cinq as mais j'ai quatre
ça pour aller dans le sens soient fous
ces cinq rois g3 après m6 qui devrait
trouver
il est sur une série de bons coureurs le
prince alors d'alger de nom mais le quai
c'était trop dur d'avoir ce tour des
huit dames g2c pas un mauvais bond soit
en fait objectivement mais après ces
niveaux le niveau de calcul de des tout
meilleurs et des tous meilleurs pas
après trois semaines de coupe du monde
déjà quasiment deux semaines
pas de façon il a coincé dans ses 5 août
à des 5,5 après peut-être qu'ils
n'avaient pas fouillé 6 x 6 par contre
ça c'est très possible et c'est là où ça
devient un minimum inquiétant dans le
sens où du coup il a à nouveau des
problèmes à résoudre et donc faut se
remettre mentalement de ces petits coups
durs il faut 1,6
un verre ouais il est peut-être que vous
des trois ça c'est très possible
ouais donc dame prenait 5 cette perf
asteelflash trois rois f26 bay 4 3 3
tours 3 échecs ça il avait ça c'est
facile web et le chrono si vous venez en
tête il ya 5 minutes ou deux je n'ai pas
remis ce que toute façon il est mal ah
ouais il est mal réglé dans les comptes
de l'allée du coup j'ai l'impression que
si on se fait proche de l'écran peut
quasiment le voir en fait est dû qu on a
le vrai quoi elles devraient le vrai
truc
mesdames c5 vraie dame 5e ça reste ce
sera le fois je crois roi f2 fou prend
b2 fin le g4 qui sera dur ok c'est
qu'ils à saïx l'arche hockey après
magnus là lui aussi là peu de temps à
attend touche le mauvais fou il parie
part il part sur fief si cela n'a envie
de jouer mais c'est parfois je crois
qu'il faut prendre un bain vrai on
devrait tous les coups sont possibles m6
prend b2 aussi parce qu'en fait c'est
pas être simple quoi priori surtout
prendre les deux c'est roger 2 ce qui
est assez complexe
je pense que la csbf 5-fu 17 c'est quoi
le savap adapté cinquième tour des huit
lasserrois g2 seul coup mais ça c'est en
fait c'est quasiment à merde face et
c'est pas introuvable parce que tu
empêches fraîche 3 et du couffo 17ème
c'est cette fois c'est l'idée c'est dur
c'est très
très dur ça c'est très très dur même si
c'était toi je serai pas confiance
j'aurais pas confiance pour ça mais te
pourrez trouver sur l'échiquier mais là
je suis resté sept étoiles serait déjà
en pls mouais moi je pensais que c'était
un truc je rêve 517 dam des cinq tours
des huit bien et puis ici et je conclus
après ce c'est pas introuvable dans le
sens où si tu vois qu'elle cinq marches
à l'avant est ce que tu dis que roi g2
que marcher séparément t'empêche fois je
crois que c'est hyper dur
max ah bah oui c'est très très dur en ce
temps là s'y trouvera g2c poupe
enfin si ce que roy jeu de ma fille qui
bat qui est orageux j'aurais peur de
fous j'ai 4 au 6 mai ont fusé qatar d'un
premier cinq tours de roue en f1
ça va aller rêve dans ces durs 3g de
c'est très dur
ah j'avais pas du tout après ce que
j'aurais eu en partie je ne sais rien
c'est toujours difficile de juger ce
qu'on aurait en partie que bon le brésil
a ya beaucoup beaucoup de parties dans
les jambes dans ses annonces d'hier
webdo aussi ça va pour le redis rêve de
ça va aussi a priori moins
moi j'aurais plus pu avoir au f 2 3 et 2
pour le génie d'un maxime c'est un round
robin qui m'attend mais là la magnus à
un moment donné il va péter un plomb il
a tout en fait
il a juste tout ça tâter schotté
s'attache au fait de ouf la highway
non mais roy g2c fou de l'avoir non
acquis c'est vraiment le présent fois
voilà là mais tu as je me demande où il
joue il joue vraiment 27,50 sur ce
tournoi bâti en fait on nous rapporte
qu'une oreillette a été trouvé dans les
bacs
l'afu 17 du coup alors attention fou 17
du cou à ces dames c'est cette excuse
est uniquement dames c'est cette recette
only mais c'est pas très dur par fait
s'interroger de ces dames c'est 7
en fait tu les trouves par élimination
maintenant c'est donc ça c'est après
west ham s'est cette fois encore avoir
souhaité cinq dames ses 580 m2 est
surfait faut quatre à barrois h 3e new
wave 3 ou non il a raté d'amd 5
bon bah c'est mort parce que là c'est
tour des 8es en fait c'est encore pire
match que les 9,3 alors quelle horreur à
la fim encore
non là c'est la méga clim tu vois il
jugé que la 3g 3 un truc du genre
mais ouais c'est assez terrible à l
était pas loin
lahouel d'amd 5 ans + wii adams et 7
pour peut-être qu'il l'a pas fait parce
qu'il a raté parce que la dame c'est
sale ça me semblait le plus facile en
fait il s'agit là vu merde
il a compris c'est pas complètement fini
après g4 ça pue mais c'est pas
complètement fini par il s'en est rendu
compte ça c'est vu là il a compris que
ces dames c'est cette en plus mais c'est
le 40e dont le site ou g4 qui a le
dommage tu aimes c'est cette juste avant
là il a deux minutes pour trouver j'ai 4
60 et 4 c'est un peu un émouvant
ouais j'en entends je suis deg
à ces terribles hayat pour ses 8 par
exemple juste bref si ça y'est fou des
quatre kits et plus fort c'est le 41e
ça c'est juste complètement fini non ça
se voit qu'il était un gain way
à ces terribles de trouver les coûts
pour ensuite mais là il ya genre aucune
chance non les pions il avance tout seul
c'est quoi les vals ça doit être
terrible dans 7 mois sept ou huit déjà m
c'est qu'après tous les quatre ça se
trouve touché 4 après le 40e
enfin après ces trois c'est moins 4 e f
ou g cat way s'est foutu de 12,8 en
photo la whey réfugiés 4 c'est facile
facile c'est depuis mon mari ce qui est
dommage c'est surtout que il l'avait
quoi ouais il était revenu après
objectivement c'était très dur en
trouver elle en a trouvé tellement en
fait un
il est prouvé ce dessin que ce projet 2
veillant à trouver on a trouvé un des co
mais c'est surtout c'est surtout ceux
d'amd 5 au lieu d'amener cette
tranquille et il a les deux joueurs qui
ont quitté la table ans et dont la
partie n'est pas finie
c'est casper purina pris la place des
deux joueurs aïe aïe aïe ça dégoûte n'en
as et terriblement juste tellement
dégoûté là
non mais bon enfin c'est tellement l'eau
tellement proches en fait
ouais l'intérim après là c'est la magie
du format chaos ça peut provoquer des
erreurs mais bon 30 minutes
je pense même qu'il va trouver que j'ai
quatre en même temps mais la position il
paraît facile pour les noirs pas des
pions pas chez soi est du coup ces
fables en fait le responsable il est
revenu et il allait revendre mais au
pire moment
c'est terrible celui mon terrible c'est
un peu sur manu sur la camarilla est ce
que je ferai pas mon trip pour les
signets ce qui est mais moi j'ai pas le
tri gate
ouais je peux pas j'ai pas de deuxième
chez parce que je peux faire
je crois qu'on peut plus rien faire et
l'a fait j'ai système pos ok il va
penser que c'est très facile à gagner je
pense en vrai salaire mais non ça ouais
moi j'essaie tâche s'annonce est
terminée c'est absolument terminer quel
dommage le drame c'est cette a trouvé
auprès des partis comme ça qu'ils sont
obligés de trouver des courants moment
tu craques invité dans l'émission idéal
g4 a pas raté dans l'élite mondiale
était dans un bon jour
en gros deux ans âge et 4 grammes c'est
que même si angers 4 fait fort
les cinq juges ou c3 tu joues si cette
étude trois essais tu pousses le prince
adam quelqu'un qui se dit qu'il ya
peut-être la déco comme seul espoir eu
des comices clique qui contient jouer
tempo mais en fait ça finira en mai si
si si officiel le seul espace kaki qui
sort les points qu'ils mettent de trois
rois et puis hôpital d' serez vous pas
qu'ils emmènent en viennent aux mains
da qui commence à taper sur la gueule
des joueurs voient la table a sacré un
g4 un mois je prends juste et 3 je ne
pose pas de question et je pense même
que c'est après ces trois s'appelle
grisaille je pense à marie zain et vite
parce qu'il allie la jouer tempo magnus
à jouer tempo tout le monde la veut le
tempo en fait présente des saints et là
c'est le froid qui va arriver al assad
doit que les deux icônes assuré je t'ai
de la partie en fait
en bref le truc marbre où ça aurait été
d'un v6 plutôt que d'emprunter 5 mais la
médaille a pas
alors et ses trois tours d2 et termina
doit même pas en fait ces trois tu
joueras g7 a plus un échec tout un
espoir des chèques et après tu peux
jouer un truc genre on ne soit tour des
deux sites à sinon pour ces huit fois f5
ils ont deux enfants qui jouent cédant
moment non je pense que là c'est le
froid ça va être sa part abandonné très
vite dans ce vrai ça peut vous envoyer
mon nom je pense en tout cas ça a été
une énorme performance de baky 1 1 c'est
terrible
5 mais roger cette baie james projet 7 à
savoir la magnus
on aura bien vibrer on aura bien vibrer
ouais mais oui c'est terrible
il ya un bug qui se terre dans le tchat
on a peut-être qui se perd mais là j'ai
plus la force
la déception est trop grande maxime ça
fait tellement place que ba qui gagne en
fait ça le problème
l'an passé à la il continue par exercice
mais on comptait jusqu'à pas envie
d'abandonner vrai
à la déception fait g5 marche très bien
réussi un ouais
oui c'est fort désir est encore demain
un miracle way
ah ouais bah celle-ci magnus si magnus
joue vraiment en mode pour faire mieux
que je sais même pas s'il va qui t'en
prends
non on attend on attend les derniers les
derniers coups la g5 si cauet marois g7
ça va ça va partir ça va avancer en fait
les noirs ont trop de en fait le roi il
est intouchable
c'est ça le problème c'est le roi est
intouchable pour celles qui savent
abandonné c'est complètement touchable
les pièces pour le faire bon il ya plus
qu'un test covit pcr la positif et ça
qui peut nous sortir élite ouais là
reste plus beaucoup de temps
les baqil et il sait que c'est foutu
oh oui
la terrible seigneur c'est fin de partie
à voir l'enfant h et j'emmène connu
aussi un terrible voilà à baky qui
gardent le sourire quand même ça va
havas et garde le sourire
ouais ouais c'est pas passé loin
voilà je pense très bien c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible
il sait qu'il a s'il a raté voile et
highline demain sera une autre partie
falloir requins qu'elles prennent à bail
un petit resto et tout mais bon il avait
il avoué
le sourd il s'est fait plaisir dans la
partie peut-être quand même donc ça va
ouais
oui oui oui savait que ce serait
difficile
ah oui vous êtes au courant et que je
l'aï gaulle en face à on a du coup les
amis on va sûrement ce qui t'es là
dessus moyenne et tout à l'heure ce sera
moi sera fabron fera l'arenal l'aréna
king mais on va la jouer vraiment
tranquille où donc ça ce sera à dire les
coups de 19h et maxime ben écoute on
compte sur toi pour requinquer ya 13 et
puis félicite le pont nous on a kiffé
ans après voilà bien sur scène et tout
c'est un yes c'est comme ça merci à toi
maxi merci à tous
yes donc les amis on perd maxime et on
va me perdre aussi donc on viendra tout
à l'heure d'ici d'ici une petite heure
avec avec fable je suis pas stéphanois
ont peut-être je jouerai pas du tout bon
on verra
il faut il faut se reprendre de cette
petite déception et à et merci à vous du
coup ciao ciao on se retrouve de toute
façon demain